[Music]
hey everybody it's bill burr on the
video camera here
uh gonna do something a little different
on the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast this week
um it's week one of nfl football
and i have the great paul verzi
uh we have a clip of us picking our uh
football games uh against the spread our
little jimmy the greek thing that we're
gonna be doing so check that out and uh
that clip will be played right after
this and then following that
um i actually have a great guest uh
sterling harjo
from the new hit show on hulu
reservation dogs and all freckles is
gonna be on this week's episode playing
a coach
um
driving instructor
see from oklahoma all right so i'm
already ready for all you guys to [ __ ]
all over me
as you always do but i think i did a
good job all right enjoy the nfl picks
and enjoy the interview
all right guys it's time to announce our
new sponsor we which we are so thrilled
to be teaming up with okay but we are
now going to be working with bet mgm
for all
all the gambling all the football and
it's mgm so you know it's a trusted name
okay uh and week one is here week one is
here we've teamed up with them and uh
this is it man the center of the
football action there's going to be so
many different bets that we have on
there
bet mgm is a brand you could trust
deposits and withdrawals are fast and
reliable so you could get your money
right away none of that waiting they
they do it the right way okay uh the
best part is this year's gonna have
special offers for our listeners
starting with this one if you
uh are new to bet mgm
use the bonus code bur that's b-u-r-r
and get 200 free after placing your
first bet uh first 10 bet as long as the
team you bet on scores a touchdown
so you're gonna make you're gonna get
money all your team has to do is score a
touchdown they're giving you a victory
to start the year who does that
get in the end zone once
again
and you're an nfl team build up your
nest egg on this bet and then you can
have a hopefully have a winning season
yes so make sure guys make sure you
download okay the bet mgm app and sign
up with code burr b-u-r-r place
first ten dollar money line bet uh on
any nfl team to win you'll get two
hundred dollars in free bets as long as
your team scores a touchdown regardless
of the outcome of the bet that is crazy
take it from me i i like a low i like a
little action
if you
if your team scores a touchdown
okay
uh they score a touchdown you get 200
bucks imagine watching your favorite
football team and you sit down on sunday
and all your team has to do is score one
touchdown and you get two c notes what's
better than that now bet mgm right now
they are live in arizona today new
jersey pennsylvania colorado tennessee
virginia indiana michigan iowa west
virginia washington d.c and wyoming so
uh if you're already if you already have
a bet mgm account don't worry bet mgm
has uh something for you too new and
existing customers will receive 20 bucks
in free bets for week one
okay
um
visit mgm
visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions 21 years of age guys
arizona colorado dc
iowa indiana michigan new jersey
pennsylvania tennessee virginia west
virginia and wyoming only excludes
michigan
disassociated persons please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step
arizona
1-800-522-4700 colorado dc
uh
los nevada wyoming virginia
1-800-270-7117
for confidential help michigan
1-800 gambler new jersey pennsylvania
west virginia 1-800 bets off iowa call
or text tennessee uh uh red line
1-800-889-9789
uh tennessee or call 1-800-9
with it
indiana okay so uh go to go to those
things
definitely gamble responsibly but have a
good time they're gonna have such great
bets for you guys um um here are some
cool bets super bowl winner check this
out bill super bowl winner
buccaneers if you bet 30 000 on the
buccaneers to win the super bowl you get
210 000 oh man i'm getting the willies
here
look at this
look at this if i throw four thousand
dollars on the g-men to win the super
bowl i get 400k
uh oh my god what's the uh what's the
patriots odds
the patriots odds for the super bowl if
you bet ten thousand dollars for the new
england patriots to win the super bowl
you get 300 big ones
okay that's a nice little i don't know
bill you should do that you got a new
quarterback
you know belichick's coming out of the
gate a little hot i might throw 500
bucks on that that's a great bet uh
conference champions here you go
conference champions let's see what it
is for the uh let's say falcons for
falcons to be conference champions you
just have to risk fifteen hundred and
fifteen dollars to win a hundred
thousand for them to win the south
patriots ten thousand wins oh this is
this is i mean i don't know this is
tough with the bills but if you give 10
000 to that bet for the patriots to win
the con conference champion you win 180
grand okay
and um and then they have super bowl
match-up stuff they also have nfl mvp
tom brady's plus 1400 so you could win
five if you bet 5 000 you get 70k
um
uh yeah aaron donald the defensive
player 500 bucks to win 100k
so all of these bets are unbelievable um
and they always offer um
half time early payouts which means if
your team is up at halftime by 10 or
more you could bounce out of the deal
because you don't want anything that you
could basically leave the bet okay so
these people are giving you 200
okay it's a reputable name it's mgm
okay
then if your team is winning by 10
points or more at halftime you could go
you know what i don't need the stress of
these other two quarters i'm out give me
my money okay and they'll give it to you
fast um the options are crazy you never
had those options
yeah when i was growing up you bet the
game you were locked in that was it
yeah so uh this is fantastic dude for
week one uh
uh the bucks are eight point favorites
okay
if you bet money line and they're up ten
points you'll just get paid out before
the game ends that is i'm not even
saying that because we're teaming up
with them that is ridiculous like for
you to be able to just bounce out of a
bet and go not is something i've
actually never even heard of
uh oh stacy's not gonna like this
okay
what games you're looking at that you
like here all right so um
i don't know dude this is nuts what is
play okay so they also have playoff dude
i'm gonna i'm gonna bet i'm gonna put
500 bucks on the paths to win it this
year
[ __ ] it
i would got to i would
um
i sent the spreads to your email paul if
you want to go through the games i sent
the spreads i just wanted to i got them
right here i got them right here i just
got to read this one line movement thing
all right
line movement means um
broncos to make the playoffs open at
plus 275. now it's plus
uh 140.
okay washington was plus 85 now it's uh
plus 185 now it's 145 and the colts to
miss the playoffs opened at 165. now
it's minus 120. so uh here's the thing
guys
don't forget if you haven't signed up
for bet mgm yet use bonus code burr burr
you'll get 200
free
for placing your first 10 bet as long as
the team you bet on scores a touchdown
so for you people that don't bet usually
this is a lot of fun you throw ten
dollars on a game you watch your team
score a touchdown and they're going to
put 200 in your account that you could
have fun with uh and and do whatever you
want you have all these different bets
to choose from including the craziest
one which i think is bouncing out at
halftime if your team is just going wild
so um definitely get the app sign up and
they're such great people it's such a
reputable company i'm excited now let's
talk about some bets
all right let's do it all right so
tonight
tampa bay buccaneers defending super
bowl champions with the great tom brady
under center going up against the dallas
cowboys what's a great franchise they
won five super bowls the the jimmy the
greek award bill burr beat me back to
back years he's a two-time jimmy the
greek award champion i have yet to i
have yet to what is it get off the
schneider i'm handicapped now i got two
kids four and under i don't know
anything about the league paul you're
gonna i'm telling you you've been
waiting for this this is like when tom
brady went to tampa and everybody's
licking their chop to play the patriots
you know what don't do this to me i know
what you're doing i know what you're
doing this is bill you know what i'm
just going to give you the money because
this is [ __ ] it's what's that
penalty and then he would win every time
i'm not buying no but i was watching
though dude
last time we did this paul i had no kids
okay well i wasn't married i had my
whole life ahead of me
all right well i'm going to give you my
first game by the way the jimmy the
greek award if you go 4-0 it's the
unimaginable if you go 0-4 it's the
unforgivable the unforgivable that's
okay um we'll pick we'll pick four games
and we'll go with that i'm gonna pick
the first game my new york football
giants are
uh wow they're two and a half point dogs
they're two and a half point dogs okay
uh against the denver broncos i'm taking
my new york giants all day to win that
game they have a chip on their shoulder
because they're dogs we've got daniel
jones some weapons so my first pick will
be the new york giants
all right
i got one for you
you know everybody was talking all about
the chiefs
they're talking all about patrick
mahomes they're going to go back-to-back
and all of this stuff and blah blah blah
blah and it didn't happen and everybody
went away i think they're going to come
out hungry i know they're playing the
cleveland browns they're in cleveland
cleveland's all excited
i think patrick mahomes is going to like
be licking his chops to shut everybody
up in the dog pound even though they're
six and a half point dogs paul i gotta
i'm picking the chiefs i'm going
actually
they're at home they're in there oh
cleveland sorry oh the arrowhead stadium
six and a half points i love that game
that's a great bet patrick mahomes
they're gonna come out emotional
kelsey's gonna be dancing before he even
makes his first catch
it's gonna be
i actually think that that's gonna be a
uh a bloodbath i think that they're
gonna kick the [ __ ] out well we're under
54 on that you think that's a high
scoring low score and bill you always
think that that's never the shootout
it's that they say it's gonna be what do
you think i can never pick over and
under i can never pick that stuff i'm
really good with the super bowl though
for some reason you know you give me a
whole season to watch somebody andrew
it's the first game of the year who
knows what's gonna uh
andrew are you are you docking these or
am i
okay so all right so uh i got the giants
plus two and a half bill has the uh
kansas city chiefs minus six that right
there's why i always seem to beat you
paul cause you bet with your heart
you went right for your home team right
out of the gate but i did something that
i normally don't do bill i took a dog
and oh you know i love a favorite oh
yeah you
i
love the favorite and speaking of that
i'm going to a favor with my second pick
my second pick is this i love that we do
the explanation too because your chief's
explanation was fantastic you know guys
there was a lot of stuff going on with
aaron rodgers
that uh he didn't want to be there there
was a lot of stuff that he wasn't happy
there was a lot of stuff that he wanted
to be traded and then you know what
aaron rodgers did like the damn
professional that he is he put his
helmet on in his red jersey and he went
to camp and he seems to be having a good
time he's staying with them and i am
going to take the the packers
against the
drew breesless
the drew breathless
saints the packers are four and a half
point favorites i thought it should be
more than that i love that number
where's that game
that game is in new orleans
okay it's in new orleans the packers are
going in as uh four and a half point
favorites i think aaron rodgers and all
them they're gonna put they're gonna
shut the door on the drama i think they
got the other team is who they got
jameis winston
and uh and that other kids number seven
i'm not buying it not week one aaron
rodgers is not gonna have the dramatic
offseason that he had and come and lay
an egg in week one i take the packers
minus four and a half
that's actually my [ __ ] bet the farm
on it of this week
yeah you're selling it paul that sounds
great to me all right
i'm gonna go with the arizona cardinals
going into tennessee
do i like it going into tennessee
oh i'm not gonna lie to you up until two
seconds ago i was thinking was carolina
just picturing their uniforms
kyla murray uh
wait who's the quarterback kyla murray
no no who's the titans quarterback oh uh
ryan tannehill
ryan tanner hill and they still have
that uh
ball of hate that gigantic
lunatic
as a running back right yes
uh henry right no i don't know i just
think kylo murray is a winner i'm going
to go with the arizona cardinals i think
they came up a little bit short they
have a little bitter taste in their
mouth
i'm gonna i'm gonna giving three
in tennessee i don't know about that
paul look good before i started talking
about it
all right
all right i like that the first week
paul i'm gonna stumble before i run
i'm gonna do something i normally
wouldn't do
okay i normally would look i normally
would look at this buffalo bills
uh minus six in buffalo against the
steelers and i would normally take i
would normally take those buffalo bills
with the spread i mean to to cover i'm
going
i'm taking the dog steelers week one
with that old gunslinger ben
roethlisberger and i'm gonna actually
take points i'm taking the pittsburgh
steelers in buffalo
getting six and a half god damn it i
like that bet too
now i can't pick the same thing you're
picking right can't do that
no
what do i got left here all right i'll
go an easy one i'm going to take the
patriots
got to bet my patriots i got to believe
the mack jones era we're giving three
points to the dolphins who always give
us a tough time but we're not down in
miami
um
and i know miami right now miami i think
miami might be looking past the patriots
because right now you know
last year the patriots finally you know
didn't have tom brady and buffalo was
able to take control of the division so
i think miami has their sights on the
buffalo bills looking past the patriots
with the kid under center
goes into gillette stadium i will beat
him like we always do i think mac jones
gets a big uh first victory his first
time out taking the pass
all right that's a good one all right so
now we got one more reach
uh
that's getting slim pickets here paul no
there's a lot of games
no there's a lot of games but i'm trying
to find one that i like here
i'm gonna do this one just because it's
opening day in las vegas
the las vegas raiders opening day
okay
uh did no justice to chris berman i love
that though there it is uh
las vegas raiders are opening up in
their new stadium this is the first
professional football game in las vegas
they are they are dogs to the ravens and
rightfully so oh paulie's right back i
thought you were gonna take the favorite
and i was gonna take the other one god
damn it paul you're learning you're
learning no no no i'm taking a favor
you're taking the favor oh you want to
do that you want to do one game when we
battle one game head-to-head dude i love
the ravens oh no i love the ravens too
but they're favorites
oh they're favorites oh okay
okay ravens the ravens are four and a
half point favorites
oh that's a great bet dude i mean part
of being a raider fan is getting excited
about something and then only have your
[ __ ] dick knocked in the dirt i think
that that's exactly what's gonna happen
yeah i like i like the i like the
favorite i'm back on the favorite on
that one so you get
you got the choice of all these last
games yeah i can't i can't bet the
wrench i just can't
i can't i can't go down on you this far
i already i i'm questioning
two of the three bets i've already made
what [ __ ] game is left oh my god the
chargers versus the washington football
team
dude
are they just are they that racist in
washington or are they just not that
good at coming up with a good how long
do you need to come up with a new name
for a team
that seems to start to seem like a
protest
um oh
wait a minute seattle seahawks in
indianapolis my boy russell wilson
with that other kid there the the
breakout wide receiver
pete carroll
oh sneaky pete
i'm gonna take the favorite seattle
seahawks minus two and a half to beat
the indianapolis colts
in that building i like that one all day
long you know until uh that kid from
stanford comes back and plus i also hate
jim irsay one of the biggest whiners
this [ __ ] game has ever seen
all right guys that's it the official
week one picks of the anything better
football uh jimmy the greek uh
championship is underway and what are we
betting paul
what what what for the season
you and i head to head what do we bet
here
like like whoever comes on top
yeah we go in money we go on a dinner
someplace
what should we do man that's that should
be a good yeah we should come up with
something really good
we should come up with something really
good um
we'll come come up with this this week
we'll figure something out i think okay
i had an idea you let me know we'll
think about but i think
whoever wins
the loser needs to take them to
the restaurant of their choice cigar
lounge of their choice the whole deal
that night is just they have to do and
take care of it on their on on their
dime oh absolutely then i'll bring you
to that that famous ice cream store in
the lower east side
oh yeah i'll get you
i'll be walking around i'm gonna take
you out paul like an absentee father
i'm just holding a [ __ ] ice cream
cone and then you're not gonna see me
for another six months
put a little money in your hand get you
some clothes big ice cream cone tie a
balloon to your wrist and then that's it
i'll see you next year
i like your bets paul i like your bets
too
i like your bets too i like amber you
wrote those down right so we can
remember them
yeah i like that kyler murray bet you
got i think arizona is going to come out
they got j.j watt too that's a good bet
um
another great thing about putting money
on games is you watch more football
yeah it's so fun dude it's it's so fun
and you know i'll be a nervous wreck
watching the giants i'll be a nervous
wreck watching the giants it's all right
i'm gonna put my i'm gonna put my money
in uh i think i'm gonna bet the patriots
and i'm gonna bet somebody else to win
the super bowl but i gotta go dogs on
both so i offset my money so i can
actually come out on top you know
and you know what's beautiful about this
season women children love it my wife
makes the chili the kids get excited
everybody's running around footballs on
every room in the house it's just it's a
blissful time man it's a blissful time
every sunday is a holiday hey
what's going on in green bay
aaron rodgers is back can't you just see
aaron rodgers just somehow you know
after
the brink of him leaving the whole thing
falling apart all of a sudden him just
coming in maybe leading him
but then you got tom brady down there in
tampa i mean they got that whole team is
back right
[ __ ] this i'm gonna i'm gonna bet the
patriots and i'm gonna bet the uh i'm
gonna bet the buccaneers
so repeat paul okay for ring number
eight
i say brady gets ring number eight and
ring number nine okay don't forget if
you haven't signed up for bet mgm just
use the code word uh burr b-u-r-r and
you'll get 200
free after placing your first
10 bet as long as the team you bet on
gets a touchdown um we're gonna go over
these next week we're gonna have a great
time with them obviously there's gonna
be team burr rooting for bill to beat me
hopefully there's some team version
hoping for me to beat bill it'll be a
good time we'll have a whole little
ceremony of the jimmy the greek thing at
the end
is there anything else guys
i think that's it
and let's go
new york football
giants
hey what's going on everybody it's bill
burns time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm just checking in on you
seeing how your week's going as you see
that it's video you know something's
going to be happening you know that i
only have special guests here every once
in a while
and uh this week is no different i have
from the new hit show on fx
reservation dogs that um it just got
already got um renewed for a season two
reservation dogs on monday on fx maybe
streaming on hulu i'm not sure one of
the creators
uh mr sterling harjo hello
what's going on man
good to see you man
you know what i think i finally worked
off uh i did an episode of the show for
people listening and uh
on my last day of the shoot
you guys got me some food that was uh
and i i don't know was that native to to
oklahoma or
it's like a native uh native
[Music]
sort of adopted it was like once they uh
started giving us flour
and sugar and things we were like all
right like i guess we can make something
with it and we made fry bread which you
had your first indian taco which i'm
very proud of
indian taco we meeting native americans
which you say you like indian better
i mean i say indian because i'm nate i'm
indian and that's what we say
i think white people say native american
um yeah well that's what we do we
slaughter you and then we give you a
nice name
so we can get we can get past our guilt
exactly yeah right
we named streets and golf courses
after stuff i remember where i grew up
everything we had like native american
names it was really uh totally and like
you know uh it's funny because you go to
these different places and it's like
they have these native american names
and it's like oh well there used to be
natives that lived here
courtesy of naming it something after
them you know but that's it
well tell me a little bit about uh this
show because i was not um
aware of it until you know my agent said
hey man there's this cool show check out
this script
i think it could be a cool role for you
and i read the script and i immediately
loved it
and then you know went out there and
went into all the whole world that was
going on out there and all you
youngsters you know compared to me
out there just killing it making this
really great show uh tell tell my
listeners you know what the show's about
how it came about yeah so the show is
about uh four native kids uh teenagers
in rural oklahoma and it's you know sort
of loosely based on aspects of my life
and also taika waititi's life who i
created with who's a friend of mine and
he and i you know we um
we'd always wanted to work together it's
funny like watching your friend you know
obviously you know he's directed
mandalorian and thor and all of that um
but watching your friends sort of
explode into this star
uh you know and we started out as
independent filmmakers together but he
had this deal at fx
and was basically like um do you have
anything that we could pitch over there
and
he and i
read each other's scripts over the years
and we both had a similar script about
kids and we decided to pitch that and it
was really fast i mean like
you know you pitch these things and i
thought like i'd hear from
tyke in a year about it or whatever but
it was literally like a few days later
um we had a pilot to write we had an
order for a pilot
shot the show
and um you know it was uh an amazing
experience and it's like i don't know
any other way to make you know you came
into the situation which i you know
thank you so much for
mentioning that you had a great time
on the show um
because i know they can be pretty boring
and um
nah that wasn't born it was uh first a
beautiful part of the country tulsa
oklahoma
one of my favorite places where uh you
know i've done stand up at the brady
theater a couple of times i've seen you
there
yeah so i was kind of excited to
go out to oklahoma in that you know
you guys don't get a lot of national
press so you're kind of like what's
going on out here let me check this out
and uh
what was it like did you did you grow up
what was that i grew up i grew up in
holdenville oklahoma which is like
an hour and a half south of tulsa super
rural 5 000 people
um
you know and we were like the biggest
town in the area so it was like
we even had suburbs which were just like
dirt roads and houses on hills but like
i grew up outside of that town
um you know it was made up of uh
i think it's like
you know there were native
native people there white people black
people and it was very mixed and like
um you know you kind of grow up with
each other in this small town
um and the show i wanted to basically
reflect that you know it was like
i've never seen my experience on tv
um
you know
tazba chavez wrote your episode and
directed your episode
and
i think that um
[Music]
you know uh but your character was based
on a coach of mine you know and it was
like you all have these like you know
coaches back where you grow up and like
yeah you know i had this coach his name
was butch rawls
and i think i told you about this guy he
uh
anytime he walked in the room he would
always say oh
and like you can be in like a bar in
boston
and if you and if there's two people
from holdenville which would never
happen but like if there's two people in
holdenville and one of them said oh
that person would hear it across the
room because it either meant like he was
about to bust your ass and give you a
swat
or make you run or do something insane
but he was a big guy
and burley football player always had a
dip in his mouth and never saw him
without a dip in his mouth
um
and you know he uh
but like that's basically what your
coaches uh because that's what i liked
about because i felt the way you wrote
it
there was so much to um
to base it off of and uh just you know
the little acting that i've done
being like in in new york what's new
york now
where it's really homogenized and then
also like kind of being out in hollywood
it's it's kind of hard to find
characters outside of crazy people
trying to make it in the entertainment
business so when i go on the road
i try to look at people and clock
different things that could be like an
interesting choice
and when i was talking to you on the
phone you kind of filled up then he used
to drink a lot too yeah there was uh was
based on two coaches one of them and
like you know later later uh whenever i
got older he would invite us over and
we'd have beer and he'd always say uh it
is he'd always say hey come on in get
you cold beer and like it was always
called
and we'd have drinks with coach rawls
and he had a big old uh
trash can full of empties you know and
we would uh help him fill that up he was
a great guy still alive still around
he's great
so what was your you know you said
something earlier that um
you saying how you didn't see yourself
on tv and as a white dude like that's
just something i can't relate to and
it's easy to downplay it
as like a white person be like well you
know i don't really relate to these
people on sitcoms or whatever but like
psychologically
like what that does to you
because i even noticed with my daughter
she's sort of gravitating towards
wanting to just watch boys do stuff
on youtube and i and i was kind of like
just asking like what was up with that
and she was already sort of
subtly getting this message that girls
don't do things boys do
so now you know i gotta watch you know
that girl that challenged dave groves as
a drum battle i have her watching that
now she wants a drum kit i you know the
those girls that were crushing it in the
olympics on skateboard so i was like
um
really uh
you have to when you said that that just
reminded me of this what was that like
when you grew up when it was just all
white basically
i mean like it was all white or it was
um
you know
you would
have once every five years you'd have a
western
and all the people that are supposed to
represent you are just getting shot off
horses and like
lying dead in front of camps and tvs and
stuff um i think that that definitely
does something to you you know like just
growing up like knowing that but like
when we were kids when you were watching
that i always wondered what the
chatter's like because i've always heard
like you know the big time hollywood
movies you know the aliens attacked the
whole world but it's always the
americans that saved the whole world
when we sit there we watch the movie
we're into it but then i heard like when
they played in france or england they're
just laughing all these arrogant
americans like laughing so you guys as
all native americans sitting around
watching whatever western came out
i mean are you guys like doing mystery
science theater just using humor to kind
of get past it yeah i mean you laugh at
it i mean i remember watching uh this
film i'm seminal native and uh there was
a film called seminole wars and my dad
was like hey come on in there's a movie
about our people you know on
and it couldn't have been more off
written by mike murphy
everyone was dressed as lakotas with big
headdresses and like they were probably
speaking comanche or something you know
and like uh but there's this weird thing
that happens where you're like
you let it slide because you're like
finally something like we're on tv like
even though it's a white guy painted and
brown-faced you're kind of like whatever
you know like it's us and we're finally
represented but then you're also
laughing at the ridiculous [ __ ] that
happens you know like
um you you do you do kind of laugh
through it but like there's also a bit
of like
pride strange pride in the fact that at
least they mentioned
your culture right now like it's in the
worst way but like at least they
mentioned it
so when you were putting together this
show
where it's finally you know
you're you're finally going to be
writing your people's or a part of your
people's uh
story culture and all that type of thing
did you feel any sort of pressure and
since the show has come out
um
has the support been there from other uh
native american people and stuff excited
that this is on or are they being like
you know that wouldn't happen like that
or blah blah blah or they being the
typical internet haters or are you still
in the honeymoon
there's definitely some internet hate um
but for the most part it's been like 90
of it's been wonderful and everybody's
responded so great of course you only
listen to the 10
and you know and like you realize like
oh i have to quit listening to any of
this [ __ ]
you know what i always do whenever
something i do comes out i just read
until the first time i get trashed yeah
then i go all right that was like you
know eight eight out of nine we're good
all right that's that's good i don't
need to read the restless i don't need
to get a big head and i'd also don't
need to stick my big head in the in the
oven so i just kind of like what do you
do you check out or
you just like put the phone away
any time i've ever had one of those
stupid you know you say something on a
talk show or whatever you just walk away
from your phone for three days like even
when it's happening so few people give a
[ __ ] yeah and it's really easy to just
get all of a sudden like in in
you know your little bubble like does
everybody care about me no they don't no
walking outside and going like are they
talking about me like what's happening
like yeah they're not because that's
what i i remember one of the first times
it happened
is i then got on the phone with somebody
i was like you know because i had that
whole dust up on the
whatever the blah blah gig or something
like that
and he goes what happened
so he didn't hear about that he's like
no
it was like another comic and stuff so i
was just like oh this [ __ ] is like
microscopic this is just it's just you
know when you're going on twitter you're
essentially reading just your thread and
the people that you follow yeah but most
of the time you know you're into
yourself so you're just reading what
people are saying about you and then you
think it's all of twitter or all of
the world whatever whatever the hell it
is so i i realized i realized that
because i started like similar to you
i started uh
talking to friends and just like you
know the whole thing
and they're like what are you talking
about like anything like oh yeah what
knows you know but like in my brain it's
like oh my god everybody's talking about
i mean but it has been crazy i will say
that i come from making independent
films
and
you know i a place where like not
everyone sees your film
to having a show that is really popular
and you know you just make these things
and you don't know
what's going to happen and you were
there i made it did you have any idea
when you were uh
when i was there i felt like i kind of
felt that little sparkle this feels like
this is special like this is gonna i
already knew because
of the subject matter i'm like this is
really different and then i just could
tell
i felt anyways because you never know
how they're gonna end up but just
the way it was written and the tone of
it
and how it was funny but it was real and
it was tragic it had all that type of
stuff i'm like all right if all of this
comes together
well i knew like i mean that was the
plan you know it was like because i
don't see tv like that you know like i'm
a big uh
you know i'm into cinema like i love hal
ashby you know where there's like you
watch harold maud or like being there
you know and it's like there's tragedy
and there's humor and it's all butting
up together i don't see that in tv much
you know for a 30 minute comedy
and but i just really approached it like
we were making an independent film of
mine which is very like a family you
know and i think like you probably felt
that you know i know bobby lee told me
he felt that and kirk
fox and um it was like fox is amazing
uh
yeah the wannabe native american guy who
runs the junkyard yeah that was such a
that was a good time that scene you guys
are so great together that's great i
can't wait for people to see your
episode
and that episode is uh i think that's
coming out this monday right coming out
monday yeah exactly
all right so everybody watch that fx and
i saw something else with hulu is it
also streaming on hulu or no
it's only on hulu and it's um
it's
what uh
fx on hulu is what it's called
fx on hulu jesus christ i mean i i can't
i was saying before i did the interview
i'm like i got to find out what channel
what time i knew it was fx and then it
was just like i was wondering why i
couldn't find a time
yeah all right
comes out um
i believe midnight
eastern time um on sunday night well
monday morning so okay i mean you know
what i've been digging into lately
what's that i've been watching the
original uh
untouchable series with robert stack
do you know what's amazing about it is
it's
i was talking about it on my podcast how
it's almost like the first law and order
where so many
amazing actors got that first tv credit
on it
because there's like uh like charles
bronson lee marvin robert redford
uh telly savalas i saw like a 22 21 22
year old james khan in it yeah um
it's just it's just it's like the
outsiders you remember that where it's
like
you know it's like
patrick swayze tom cruise emilio estevez
rob lowe
like
ralph macchio was just every everybody
in it
went out and headlined a movie or
starred in a movie and had a run
however long yeah matt dillon yeah
matt dillon too that's right dude for
johnny and that day
and that was in uh every time i go to
khalsa
you know dean del rey my buddy he tells
me goes you got to go see the outsider
house man it's right down the street and
i never get around to it
but i did
i did get a chance to see my first bald
eagles which i had never seen one unless
it was like in cap captivity
well i didn't realize that the old ones
had the white feathers and the younger
ones kind of had like the brown or
whatever so i'm 99 sure
because i went to that museum where they
you then look out into the oh yeah
there's eagles out there the gilchrist
probably that's what i went to yeah
there's definitely eagles out there
yeah so i i mean like tell me about your
first time in tulsa could you because
you know it's a small city so it's like
chatter around town was all like hey
bill burr likes it here man he's
mentioned us a couple of times oh okay
so i yeah i'm going to tulsa oklahoma so
i think it's going to be a bunch of [ __ ]
kickers and wranglers
cowboy boots with the spurs on it you
know and a spittoon like i have no idea
what it's going to be and i went there
and i immediately noticed like man
there's all these great places to eat
there's a really like a art scene going
on here i'm feeling like there's a live
music thing going on
and um
and then i went into the brady theater
and the promoter had this old cadillac
from the early 70s yeah that like i
remember he let me drive it one of those
things where you feel it wanting to
lurch forward before you even put it and
drop it like the idle's so high and then
i just kind of she's driving this big
thing down he let me take it around the
block and
um you know i am a lover of old
sports stadiums and that type of stuff
so i went and
since doing stand-up it's now become
that with like theaters and everything
so to go into brady theater i forget
who's played there but i definitely
looked up and i asked people and they
were like oh willie nelson and all of
these guys and i saw tom waits there man
like i mean one of my favorite shows
ever was tom waits at the brady theater
man there's some great great shows yeah
i can you could it's funny because you
like when you walk in there
that was one of the things when i went
to the breakthrough i was like oh man
everybody's played here oh yeah dylan
you know like dylan you see him walking
around town
before his show and stuff it's pretty
great yeah it seemed like you guys kind
of like you have a little bit of what's
going on in a lot of cities but
hopefully not a lot where they
they keep knocking down old [ __ ]
not only old [ __ ] but like places where
it's something to go do something
and then they just put up some glass
tower of
of high end yeti yet again high-end
departments which um
oh i don't understand how everybody a
little bit i mean there was this uh bar
that everyone used to go to called the
sound pony and you would and it was
great because at a back patio you had a
view of downtown
and it was this place it was next to the
keynes ballroom which a lot of bigger
acts play there but the sound pony was a
place that smaller acts could come
through and play and there's like punk
shows and things like that
and
we just kind of came up going there and
one of the best things was you had this
view of downtown in the from the back
patio
and then all of a sudden high-rise
four million dollar lofts get built
they're being built right now and it's
just like you go back there now and you
feel like you're in this like closed off
alley you know it's just like
it's just like yeah and the thing is
like
well who has the money in tulsa oklahoma
to do that
yeah who's spending four million dollars
for an apartment
yeah and what are you looking just so
you can look down on people
yeah yeah yeah
um yeah i don't understand it i i did
want to take the time to talk to uh
about some of the people that i you
already mentioned um
uh taz but also uh devry jacobs uh and
then i met some of the other actors who
weren't
um
in the uh episode that i was in it just
seemed uh
man devry you and devry are so great
together like oh thank god he's great
right i mean like just
like
it's so good like you guys this kind of
odd couple story that ended up together
you know it's fantastic and what's cool
is like most of it takes place in a car
you know which i love yeah no i'd be
honest with you there was a lot of that
stuff that i don't know give away the
episode but a lot of it you know
certainly where we were shooting and
everything reminded me of one of my
favorite movies uh no country for old
men oh yeah you know like when we were
driving in between like sets or like
when at the motel oh so very very
tarantino's sort of very no country too
you know just yeah
you know which i love about that movie
is when that whole shootout thing
happens that they don't show it like
it's just so brilliant no it's beautiful
i mean like that's the thing about like
what i love shooting here
is there's so many locations
so many locations
um
that
you don't i mean like i would hate to
just be stuck in stages right like doing
like shooting and sound stages and stuff
because like you get to go out to these
places and find these amazing and i
think that's part of what people talk to
me about the show and why they like it
is it feels like you're in a different
place you know like you feel like you're
uh it's a location they've never seen
and like you know this is cheesy and
people say this a lot but it's like the
location definitely becomes like a
character a bit you know i mean like
i've got like the uh
you know uh the
the renty bros uh salvage yard where
kirk fox and them where you go in the
episode to see the the guys at the
salvage yard i mean that place is rad
you know and it's just like these you
know this
uh this old black man owns it and like
you we showed up there and he was like
we were like we'd love to shoot here
he's like yeah man he loves us like
we're like he's ready
he's super excited for season two he
loves to hang out but i wanted to buy
there was like a couple of trucks in
there that i saw that i liked a couple
of i think the car we end up sitting on
too was a cool one i'm trying to
remember what they were but there was
some uh there was some good [ __ ]
stuff in there good stuff yeah yeah for
sure and it's like got that rusted feel
i don't know i mean like you know you
mentioned the coen brothers and i've
always been a big fan of their work and
kind of that world and like it's always
like you know it's not gritty reality
but it's a heightened reality and i like
i think that's what this show is you
know it's like it's there's a bit of
magic to it and it's showing this world
that no one's ever seen before and it's
kind of like
i think of it as like you know i have a
nostalgia for the way that i grew up in
rural oklahoma
and i don't think people necessarily
understand that world or or understand
what it's like
and they definitely don't like aren't
used to meeting like a native person
with a country accent or like something
like that you know so like
i just wanted to show this and it was
kind of like this you know as a bit of
nostalgia from the way i grew up and you
know i don't know if it
necessarily you know like
so you know and also kind of giving
homage to all these movies that i love
growing up which i think like when you
grow up in rural
areas
you kind of see things through pop
culture right like you you live your
life
through movie references and music and
oh yeah yeah so we have these like
homages to like
you know i mean i mean in your episode
license to drive but like you know these
like platoon homages and all this stuff
you know and it's like uh
i don't know just sort of the innocence
of kids or whatever you know just like
kind of living their life and dreaming
of leaving i think i remember making
friends with people because someone
would do an obscure line from a movie
that i loved
the second you like oh my god is that
from no
i remember like one of my my uh
people
out as chris masili who runs the gotham
comedy club
and he made this reference
to uh pope at greenwich village
oh yeah
that tough uh talking about the uh the
mozarella at this restaurant tough like
[ __ ] that
yeah the only guy
he said that i was just like keep
[ __ ] remember it's like there's so
many great lines in that movie but like
me and a buddy of mine when i used to
work in this warehouse before i got into
this business
we used to always um watch that movie
and that was one of the lines that stuck
out and nobody
a lot of people haven't even seen that
movie and nobody if they did it was
always charlie they took my thumb and
they know the iconic things that people
say in that but he was the only guy that
picked out that obscure one i was like i
like this guy yeah yeah
hey can i i want to ask you a question
as far as like you know just
native americans like living on
reservations and everything like that
like
so that's the land that
that white people gave native americans
or placed them on after they moved them
and did all the other horrible stuff
what are the options like if you are on
a reservation are you free to just be
like yeah hey man i'm
going to go to usc or i'm just going to
go do something over here how does that
work
yeah i mean nowadays like well and
oklahoma's different because like
oklahoma used to be sort of one big
reservation or one big
territory that had a lot of reservations
in it
um that's why it was called indian
territory back in the day and then you
have you know other reservations that
are more closed off like our our
reservation isn't closed so white people
everybody can live
in the borders of that land
um
so
there's nothing keeping you there you
know other than either something
cultural or yourself or family or
whatever
um and i think that there is a
hesitation sometimes when you grow up
with native communities to not leave you
know because
you know whatever like this
you feel like you're selling out or is
it just
one of those just i'm not leaving my
hometown it's kind of a complicated
thing of like you know you want to help
because there's so little of you and
you know you're the the fear of like
losing culture i think
is
the fear and also the importance of
culture is kind of instilled in you and
how unique your culture is like if you
leave this place you're not gonna find
people with the same language as you and
like the same customs as you or our
traditions um so there's a bit of like
holding on to what you have and there's
a pressure to stay because of that
um
and you find a lot of times i think
that's kind of what this shows about
honestly is like different people do
different things you know like i left um
and
did you wrestle with that
leaving yeah definitely i still do i
mean like i still live in oklahoma which
is
technically on the muskogee reservation
you know and so like
um i live here because i want to be
close to the culture and the people um
and i think you definitely wrestle with
that because you're a part of the demise
if you leave sometimes but there's also
people that leave and go do amazing
things and then sometimes they bring
those amazing things back and whatever
talents they learn whether they're
doctors or whatever they can come back
and help their people
um so yeah it's always a complicated
thing i think it's like that with
anybody from a small community a tight
community
that's really cool um
what are your uh when you went to pitch
this thing
um
just out of curiosity because you know i
always know when you're going to pitch
something they always go like
okay we love the idea
we love the characters and blah blah
blah where do you see these people in
like
five years and stuff did when you did
the pitch just out of curiosity did you
pitch them
the three season arc or the five season
arc or or did they just know that there
was
this is such like an untapped area of
humanity that you know
that the episodes would be coming it was
definitely that i mean
but the way it started was taika i tyken
i came up with the idea i wrote him a
little document sent it to him the next
day
a couple days later he had dinner with
garrett bosh who's the producer of what
we do in the shadows
together they called fx
and basically said you have 45 minutes
to buy this or we're taking somewhere
else
and they were like
wow
and they were like well
they've never heard anything about like
natives that were funny they were like
i've never heard anything like this like
we'll do it so i literally had a deal
that day for to write a pilot i didn't
even have to go in
and then
out of courtesy we went in like a month
later taika and i and just sort of
talked to them about the show in person
and i think just
from taika and i spit balling what the
possibilities were they knew that there
were multiple seasons you know
how was the room
was it a cold room was it a cool room to
pitch in or what it was very uh
welcoming i mean taika
makes any room
kind of like
it's like they're like you know putty in
his hands or whatever i get it he gets
them to chill and then like oh okay
farming everybody loves being around
them you know and so like he walks in
tells a couple jokes lays on a couch
and then like everyone's ready you know
and it's fine so
it was really easy actually doing it
with him i i and like honestly i can't
believe how fast it went because like
we were shooting the we wrote the we
wrote the pilot
and
taika was coming out to direct the pilot
and then the pandemic happened we got
shut down
and then
they were like we're committed to this
show
we'll hire you to write four more
episodes so
i wrote four more up i wrote three more
episodes
and
now do you have a roma do you write by
yourself at that point i didn't have a
room i just wrote the three episodes
during the pandemic
and then they were like all right we
love these let's order the room they
ordered the room we wrote the rest of it
and
then we were shooting
oh no first i wouldn't shop the pilot
and tyga had to go make thor so i ended
up directing the pilot and that was when
they kind of loosened up the the covet
stuff we were able to go shoot the pilot
they loved it they ordered the room we
wrote the rest of it and then we went
and you know that's when you came out we
shot the rest of the series um it was
really fast i mean it was super fast
when you when you put together your room
where were they cool with whoever you
wanted to go in there yeah man because i
was like you know i want my friends to
write this like my native friends that
are talented and like i wanted to there
you go you became that guy you know
you left you did something and then you
came back and you hooked people up and
it's like you know the beauty of that
was like
in that writer's room and it's not like
i would only ever write with native
people but this specific story because
it's about a community it's like
there was there was a shorthand i didn't
have to explain anything we all started
off from this place of like commonality
where like
we could just tell the story and tell
the jokes and talk about funny stories
that happened to us back home
no one had to explain anything and it
just went really fast and really good
and then they you know a lot of the same
people came and directed those episodes
as well like toss but tosma was her
first time tazbo who directs your
episode i mean it's such a good episode
i loved her manchester it was she was a
lot of fun the way she directed she has
got a really cool style real cool style
and like super like um
i mean like she would call me at like
two in the morning and be like i'm
researching this thing about that i'm
like what are you doing like you know
she was just really hard to take care of
business you know and like which is
great and um but she came in and just
like did it and like she had never
directed tv before and um
you know just to give people the
opportunity to shine like that was that
her deal was was she uh a writer on the
show or a performer who was a writer on
the show she wrote your episode and then
um she directed your episode and that's
the only episode
before before she directed was she
helping you write the other episodes she
she helped write the other episodes but
she had made a couple short films before
that so
she was old friend of mine and i just
knew that she was talented and you know
uh it didn't really take any convincing
at all i mean fx i mean that's what i'll
say about fx is they've been like uh
creatively super hands off and just kind
of encouraging on everything on every
front
well dude i think obviously man you
already got renewed you got lightning in
a bottle over there it just felt like
all this new
new blood going in there which is has
kind of
been like uh you know something that's
it's weird has been happening in my life
lately i think that's maybe how i ended
up
somehow getting sucked into the show
which is awesome because uh
the comedy store you know all of these
people joe and all of them left which
sucked
but then all this new blood came in and
just sort of was like okay this is still
stand-up comedy but there's this whole
new energy
just a different thing in there and i
really got that vibrant on your show so
i i want to make sure i take the time to
thank you
for thinking of me
and put me on that thing and i hope
people uh
like the episode and uh
it's gonna really knock people over man
it's a really good one
okay and real quickly how many how many
episodes are per season eight episodes
so yours is the seventh episode and then
there's the finale and then we go into
riding the next season and then the next
season is is there going to be eight
again is it ten ten the next season and
the next season oh okay so they give you
a little more time to tell the story
that's right so now do you have that
like uh
on f is for family you know
mike price the great mike price he would
always we'd have the war room you know
the big
bulletin board i'm always fascinated
with how people put it together we would
just have each character was a different
you know color card or something like
that and we would just sort of track
like how are we gonna do this so you
know i mean we had a zoom right we had
to do a zoom room so it wasn't even a
real oh my god yeah which is crazy so
like you're literally looking at faces
like this
and then you have um
a writer's assistant who is pulling up
the software and like laying out
the axe structure or the character cards
on specific software and you're really
just talking through the stuff and you
record it so you can keep it in case you
need it you know and um
well you're like super chill man do you
ever get like frustrated like some days
like when i would be in the writers room
you know days when it isn't working
i would just get my brain would just get
like i mean i wouldn't flip out i would
just be like
oh there were times when i blew it up
like where i would go home and we would
have like
all the episodes kind of
broke and like we're ready to go and
then
i would go home and eat an edible or
something and like getting like a
get into like a panic mode and just be
like oh my god this is not the show like
this isn't the show like we [ __ ] up
and then i would like come in the next
day and just like we're we're [ __ ]
destroying all of it like we have to
really like blow it up and figure out
where the show is you know and everyone
would be like oh
but then like inevitably someone will be
like well you're right
think about this and like let's think
about this and then we would rebuild it
back up and it was better you know i
think that that was kind of key in
making the episodes really good
uh i really admire that work ethic
because i got to tell you once i get on
that because trying to pull it back
apart again which is why i needed mike
price yeah one of the many reasons why i
needed him to do efforts for family
because i literally get to the point i
think it's because the way my brain is
and also that i do stand up where it's
just like here's this joke it didn't
work all right i'll make fun of myself
moving on i don't have to stop and fix
it and i just think i'm just wired to
just
keep going and the stopping and the uh
what did they always say well you know
right writing is rewriting yeah totally
yeah there's all these things like a hat
on a hat or like whatever you know all
of that [ __ ] then i also hated like it's
like all right we need to do a rewrite
and we would go back and do a rewrite
and it's just like newest joke wins not
funniest joke
it's newest joke so then you're pitching
on a joke
that already worked it worked at the
table read and everybody's you know
sitting there and somebody throw some
out and then it's [ __ ] in there and
that would always be you know that was
my one job be like dude this new joke is
not as good as the old one yeah i've
never been in a writer's room right like
i never i've never been in one so like i
don't know anything but the zoom
writer's room and i i wonder if i would
not i feel like i would not like the
writer's room
the actual writer's room because like
people are sitting around like eating
snacks and like you know like looking at
the ceiling or whatever like taking the
mental breaks yeah exactly here you're
like locked in you can't do much
except look at this screen and get
hypnotized by it you know so i kind of
wonder if it gets weird whenever it's
harder whenever you're in a room
together with all the brakes well
overall it was an awesome experience on
efforts for family and i learned how to
write a script and i met all these great
friends just amazing
these kids that we had that helped me
write the thing and um and then some of
the older guys were like mentors and i
watched like how they did it
and uh
overall it was good but like i i didn't
understand in the beginning when i first
got into writer's room that i didn't
need you i mean you're the show runner
so you have to be but i didn't realize
like i don't need to be thinking
the entire time yeah every single i can
take a half a page off
and i'm not gonna i can't leave the room
but i'm gonna recharge i i kind of just
the late great mark wilmore i used to
notice he would do that he would just
sort of sit there
almost like he was sitting on the bench
and just having his head down and stuff
sometimes with his eyes closed
and i was thinking like man is he
sleeping like what's going on all of a
sudden his head would come up
and then i mean i you know like those
times are desperate on the room i feel
like whenever it's a zoom room because
you have those moments where you're just
like
for like 30 minutes of just like
can't figure it out you know like maybe
an hour i mean like the worst was when
we would end the day
not figuring it out
and had to leave and it was just left
undone that would nag at me
but sometimes that's a good thing
you even walk away like 12 hours you
come back some of the stuff looks like
somebody else wrote it exactly you got
like a fresh idea well that makes me
feel good because i just i just you guys
when i went out there made it look like
yeah you know we just sat down you know
pitched it wrote it
got it
yeah try this try this uh
by the way i love by the way uh your
coach bobson uh i love the references
that you gave me which was like you know
barry switzer and i love that like i
just love like because you know like
you're a sports guy but oklahoma is oh
you and
you know especially like native people
in oklahoma ou is a big deal and i just
grew up like
you know every ou game it was the heyday
you know of the 80s and like
brian bosworth and stuff
when i was a kid i had the bosworth
haircut stuff and like uh
i did i was on the news one time for it
but like you know we would my parents
would go to a friend's house and they'd
be boozing
and i've never heard such yelling
during the heyday of ou
we'd be playing or hanging out and a
play would happen and the room just of
like five or six people would just erupt
and
the windows would be shaking you know
and it was just like there's never been
like as much excitement about ou
football as in very swift but you know
it was also smaller man nobody in there
could be like on their phone and looking
at all of this stuff like you just were
like everybody was just
it was everything was such a big deal
yeah whatever you were it was you know
it was king then you know it was like oh
yeah
like he was the best yeah well listen
man i'm so happy for you guys over there
i'm so happy that you guys put me in and
you guys are making this show you can
stream it on hulu it's called
reservation dogs it's so great they
already renewed it for a second season
uh sterling thank you so much thank you
for those great cigars you got me too uh
i hope coach bobson comes back at some
coach he's coming back
all right good deal good deal so all you
guys listening please check it out um
you can watch it uh i guess monday it'll
come up midnight sunday night sunday
night yeah all right thank you thank you
guys for watching the uh thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast all right go for it
all right it's helix everybody alex
um finding the right mattress can be a
chore
but don't put it off sleep is important
to your health helix sleep quiz
uh sleep sorry helix sleep has a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and your
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else
with helix alex you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep everybody is
unique everybody's special and helix
knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot gross
uh mattress is great for spinal
alignment
jesus you're gonna put chiropractors out
of business to prevent morning aches and
pains and even a helix plus mattress for
plus sly sleepers
all the big boys tired of falling out of
the bed they got a big mattress for you
so
if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to and the mattress
comes right to your door shipped for
free you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store again just go to
helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up gross
uh for you if you don't love it but you
will helix says even has financing
options and flexible payments plans so a
great night's sleep is never far away
helix is offering up to 200 dollars
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com that's helix
sleep.com for up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows
just heard somebody bang the [ __ ]
hotel room upstairs
maybe they're mad at me
for being too loud here all right
uh oh mack weldon everyone
you're a busy guy
so stop thinking about what to wear and
just embrace the radically efficient mac
weldon
daily wear system the daily wear system
is a selection of clothes rooted in
smart design made with performance
fibers
and built to work together from
breathable t-shirts and polos to stylish
buttons up in shorts and beyond mac
weldon makes it easy for you to dress
for work leisure and play and wherever
your summer may take you
for the ultimate lazy sunday there's ace
sweatshorts
have modern tailing
tailoring and perfectly uh and
ace sweatshirts have modern tailoring
and pair perfectly
pair perfectly who who talks like that
with their ultra soft ultra upgraded
pima tees
p-i-m-a pima
an easy comfortable outfit for a day out
on the golf course and out on the beach
for weekend travels both near and far
what do you need the silver knit polo
and radius shorts
they cover your dick and balls the whole
way around the whole radius of your junk
are the perfect high-tech highly
packable combo um buy some this summer
with the mac weldon daily wear system
for 20 off your first order visit mack
weldon m-a-c-k-w-e-l-d-o-n
dot com slash burr and enter the promo
code bird that's
mackweldon.com promo code burp for 20
off mack weldon radically efficient
wardrobing
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
september 9th
uh 2013.
is that what year it is 2013 absolutely
it is
um
how's it going
how are you did you have a good week i'm
[ __ ] out of it because i had to get
up at five o'clock this morning
and i had to do a bunch of phones for uh
upcoming shows you know answering all
the questions
some good
some bad some repetitive
but you know it's what you do as a
professional you answer them every time
like it's the first time
so uh how do you uh how do you come up
with your material is it something do
you write every day or is it more spur
of the moment what strike what strikes
you
as funny
and then you got to go into it well you
know yeah i used to write now i know and
i just got a [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
teardrop coming out of your eye
but um whatever
whatever so here i am i'm [ __ ] groggy
you know what's you know what sucks is i
used to be a morning person
i really did but granted i also used to
go to bed at like [ __ ] 9 30 10
o'clock at night because when i was a
young fella a little lad with orange
hair
running around the playground trying not
to get the [ __ ] kicked out of me whilst
bullying people smaller than me that's
how you did it back then all right you
beat the [ __ ] out of me i can't beat the
[ __ ] out of you i have this awful
feeling oh i'll take it out on that
little kid over there smaller than me
that's the way it was done it was the
70s it wasn't social networking
okay people couldn't get all get on and
be like hey sign this petition man and
let's end the bullying
it wasn't you just had to go to school
every day and you [ __ ] took it
and no local news reporter came down and
i didn't get to go on the [ __ ] tv
with my stupid freckle face you know
lower bottom lip quivering as i tell the
story
of somebody who beat the [ __ ] out of me
nobody cared
all right that was it
so anyways
now i'm in this [ __ ] business so i'm
not a morning person i just have a paper
with everybody i just get up at the
crack of [ __ ] dawn
you know jump on a bicycle
be pitch black out in the wintertime
freezing my [ __ ]
small balls off
pre p is it pre-put besan how do you say
that word [ __ ] balls off you know
nostrils sticking together
and nobody gave a [ __ ]
this is this is back when a child did
that job that nowadays an adult has to
do the job either because the dollar is
so [ __ ] weak or because that chris
hansen has everybody so paranoid that
there's some pervert with his dick out
behind every goddamn tree out there
that's why you got fat kids right did i
do a bit about this back in my [ __ ]
earlier stand-up days i can't even
remember i'm so tired right now
but yeah we used to do that [ __ ]
parents didn't hover over children
didn't have play dates none of that [ __ ]
what it was was your mom fed you
and then there would be you know she'd
get sick here right around when like the
game show started coming on and then she
would just open the door and just be
like you kids need to go outside go
outside and you just go outside and
there was other kids that were also
banished to go outside and then you'd
link up
and then you just went about your
business
you fought you tied kids to trees you
threw fireworks at them you played with
matches you threw [ __ ] in people's pools
you vandalized a new house that was
being built you know sweet innocent fun
like huck finn and tom sawyer
that's what the [ __ ] you did
but uh those days are all gone now
you keep kids inside and you feed them
and you get them big and fat that's what
you do well that was the bitter you get
them so fat that they're unfuckable
right
is that what it was i can't remember
what if there's a pervert who's into fat
kids
you know there's a lot of holes in my
jokes this week people i'm not going to
lie to you um
so anyways i hope you guys had a good
week how great is it that nfl football's
back
[Music]
i actually went to the uh the denver
broncos um
who the hell did they play the ravens
so i get into this big uh text battle
with paul versey paul verzi's going like
uh dude it's a lock take denver give him
10 points it's a log dude i called it
and all this type of [ __ ] right typical
version
and i'm sitting there going like paul
it's the first week of the season
nothing's a [ __ ] lock you have no
idea okay you're throwing a [ __ ] god
you're throwing a boat into the ocean
all right
it's not even expression
um
but i like it okay if you can't do the
math on that i can't [ __ ] help you
all right
anyways so
he's telling me it's a [ __ ] lock and
i'm just going like you know 10 points
i know ed reed's not there i know ray
lewis isn't there they still got a
defense they still got joe flacco
they got ray rice i mean ray rice can
eat up a lot of goddamn clock and as
good as peyton manning is
if he doesn't have the ball what the
[ __ ] he going to do
so uh i i another thing that bugged me
was everyone on espn was picks picking
the broncos paul verses picking the
broncos everybody i know is saying the
broncos are gonna kill him
like this [ __ ] team
wasn't just in the super bowl last year
beating the 49ers
getting 10 points so i said [ __ ] it
i think the ravens are going to win
we're not win i think that they're
they're going to cover
and uh the first half went exactly
how i said it was going to go ray rice
was running all over the place chewing
up the [ __ ] clock
joe flacco never looked good but he was
looking good enough
defense had a big hit right in the
beginning
and uh things were looking all right
and then the second half came
and it was just it was over
broncos were like all right we can't run
uh let's go into a hurry up offense joe
flacco looks like he hasn't thrown a
[ __ ] ball since the last one he threw
in the super bowl he's got his big
contract he got married
let's say we uh blitz him every other
play and see how he deals with this [ __ ]
and they [ __ ] didn't make any
adjustments and i sat there
watching one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time have one of the
greatest performances of all time and i
could not enjoy it just sitting there
knowing that paul versey was going to be
right and i was going to be wrong and i
was literally sitting there
fuming
for like 24 [ __ ] hours
that the [ __ ] ravens had no answer
to the broncos halftime adjustments the
fact that i was [ __ ] sitting there
with paul verzi i mean with jason
lawhead going like dude the broncos
can't run the ball they should just
[ __ ] throw it now
and throw it to the sidelines because
he's [ __ ] picking them apart it's
exactly what the [ __ ] they did
i thought what's his face was going to
settle down jesus christ joe flacco i
finally believe in the guy
never believed in the guy i know it's
only one week but he looked [ __ ]
horrific
so
i'm not saying he's going to be horrific
all year but uh anyways long story short
i had a great time and i really should
have enjoyed watching peyton manning
throw for seven touchdowns because that
was a legendary performance in any era
even with the new rules of passing where
you're just supposed to escort the
[ __ ] uh receiver down the field and
get out of the way when the quarterback
under throws him and [ __ ] it was still
an unbelievable performance and i was
actually had great seats
and uh he threw a couple of [ __ ]
balls
like they looked like they were coming
at our seats
and you know the receiver came back and
caught him he just got to see the speed
of the nfl and how [ __ ] accurate
manning was it was amazing
to watch it if i wasn't such a [ __ ]
grumpy [ __ ]
uh during the game
um
and i got to tell you i i actually
enjoyed uh
watching the patriots trying to figure
out
what we're going to do now on offense
now that gronk is hurt
and hernandez is uh looking at some
serious jail time
um
i don't know i actually enjoyed watching
them play the [ __ ] bills
i got to see a whole other level that's
what it's going to be this year
it's going to be uh watching
brady
do what he does best which is make
people around him even better and that's
what the truly great ones can do
you know
and that's why i have issues with some
people that they say are great but
they're just individually great they
don't make people uh better around them
in fact they borderline annoy people
around them kobe bryant um but you know
i'm not gonna name names
so uh
i don't know we shall see this is going
to be a tough season
for i think the patriots i don't know i
don't know how good we're going to be
this year it is it is early on
but uh but i'm all right with it this is
when you actually become a true fan when
your team is in a [ __ ] lock
and uh i like that that quarterback that
the bills had ej manuel i like the fact
is that his last name i can't even
remember but the fact that the guy can
[ __ ] run
but uh he didn't seem like he only ran
as a latch as a last like ditch like i
just got a [ __ ] run he seemed like he
tried to use his speed more to stay in
the pocket and throw
so uh they look pretty goddamn good to
me and that's it for my boring ass
football talk how'd you like that
everybody how about a funny story bill
all right how about the fact that i have
a bruise on my back the size of a
[ __ ] softball
how'd you get that bill well i decided
to go hiking
in the rocky mountains in the beautiful
state of colorado
i went up there with rose bowl legend
jason lawhead
you know
we went up there like we were on a
second date let's go on a hike do you
like hiking too i'm so excited so we
decided to go on this [ __ ] hike and
i'm nervous going into the rocky
mountains because i'm thinking they got
bear you know [ __ ] elk barracuda
whatever the [ __ ] they got up in there
you know what i mean
this is the real deal
this isn't like the [ __ ] hollywood
hills out here where you know i'm going
to run into [ __ ] kevin bacon before i
run into any sort of [ __ ]
you know
i'm going to run into [ __ ] louis de
palma before i run into even a bobcat
out here that's all it is maybe lee
majors if he's in a bad mood maybe he'll
[ __ ] throw something at me that's the
worst i have to worry about out here
these are the [ __ ] rocky mountains
all right these are the mountains that
they create cause light with this is the
real deal
so um
we're going in there you know with
nothing but [ __ ] you know our workout
clothes i have no weapon on me
everything is telling me this is [ __ ]
stupid
and uh
we're in boulder colorado which i'm
telling you man boulder colorado
arguably the best the most in shape
people i've ever seen in my [ __ ] life
we were sitting there walking up this
this this hiking trail and we're all you
know there's a part of me i'm [ __ ]
nervous because i haven't gone up there
i'm with somebody who hasn't gone up
here this has all the makings of one of
those readers digest i almost [ __ ]
died stories that they have in there and
all of a sudden this [ __ ] lady
she had to be in her late 50s
comes
running down the trail people
not walking
running
wearing those sneakers that look like
feet that are [ __ ] annoying but you
have to look at him with this spring in
her step
like walter payton running on the balls
of her feet came running by
barely breaking a sweat
big smile [ __ ] glow in her face
hadn't let life beat her down or
anything it was unbelievable
and i'm like me and jay but at that
point we've been
we'd been in um
in boulder for like three days we did
the show at the boulder theater did two
shows they were [ __ ] awesome
uh unbelievable crowds great theater
uh part of the billy red state tour the
rescheduled one and everybody showed up
and uh was awesome
uh the next day we went to the broncos
game and then this was
the morning we were going to drive down
to colorado springs we were like well we
got to work off all the booze we drank
at the broncos game so we decided to go
on this [ __ ] hike all right all right
i'm back on track here so we go into the
into the wilderness
with no weapons or anything and you know
i'm nervous
i mean that lady running by made me feel
good but for half a second i'm like is
she running from a mountain lion
because people where i'm from in their
in their early 30s can't run that fast
so we go up the hill and uh
it's just amazing
it's [ __ ] amazing like it's so
beautiful you're like whispering
like oh my god look at those [ __ ]
look at the view like that type of [ __ ]
right but i'm also nervous like uh
i just got this feeling like i don't
know i just don't want to get my face
ripped off i mean call me weird call me
a coward i don't give a [ __ ]
getting mauled
is not on my bucket list
okay
that just sounds
so much worse than getting stabbed and
shot because it like get you get stabbed
and shot from unless you get riddled
or stabbed multiple times for the most
part you have a wound but it's it's in
one area
one of your limbs hurts the other three
can still use you get mauled that is
just an all-encompass encompassing like
it's like you went through a paper
shredder
all right i i i don't need that
so
we're about half hour into the hike
and i'm like wow i'm a half hour into
the rocky mountains with no [ __ ]
weapon and my guide is a fellow stand-up
comedian
so we decide to sit down
on these rocks i'm like let's sit down
just take a break because we're [ __ ]
winded
because we're middle-aged guys we're out
of shape and we're
a mile high right in denver or whatever
boulder
so we sit down on these rocks and i'm
like nervous looking around making sure
there's nothing
deciding to [ __ ] pounce on me
and all of a sudden i hear a car drive
by
and i'm like what the [ __ ] and like a
hundred yards away there's like a road
and then i looked over another 20 feet
and it was like a picnic table
so evidently this [ __ ] trail we were
going on this isn't like some deep
forest [ __ ]
like we pulled off the road evidently we
could have just kept driving and gone
all the way up to the top so in the
trail we're on crosses the road a couple
of times so we're we're totally fine for
the most part
so i see the picnic table and i point at
it to jason we just start [ __ ]
laughing because we're sitting down on
these rocks like we're lewis and clark
and we're in the middle of nowhere and
we're we're [ __ ] we're right there
we're in the middle of silver
civilization
long story short we get all the way up
to the top
um
we're standing on these rocks we're
looking down actually looking down into
uh was it finley stadium whatever where
the uh the buffaloes play
absolutely gorgeous we're so high up we
could see the denver the skyline in
denver it was [ __ ] awesome so we
start walking back
and uh we're coming down the trail and
it's you know really loose kind of dirt
and we keep slipping but we're all right
you know we keep regaining our balance
and at one point lawhead slips to the
point where i thought he was going down
and he was able to recover
you know he was an athlete and i said i
said that was nice you can see you you
know you played hoop yeah you got
athletic background i said had you been
joe derosa
um
i'd be carrying you down off the
mountain and we were sitting there
laughing at joe right because that's the
kind of friend i am i throw my friends
under the bus when they're not there to
defend themselves
so
wouldn't you know karma comes back and
bites me in the ass like a [ __ ]
minute later
i'm standing there taking a picture or
something
and i go and i take a step or two dude
and i'm telling you it's like somebody
took my legs out i don't even know what
happened
i just fell
and i landed on a rock
like
first of all my my elbow scraped first
on my right arm and it pushed my
it like hyper extended like i almost
snapped my [ __ ] humerus and all i was
doing was falling from a standing
position
down to the ground in the dirt but there
just happened to be this [ __ ] rock
there
and i almost and i think i would have
broke it but fortunately
the rest of my body hit the the other
part of the rock basically
just imagine jumping up in the air so
you're horizontal and then just landing
on the rock with like a baseball sized
part of your back
dude i i wish i could recreate the
the [ __ ] noise i made
um
and i that was it i was just down and i
was down for like a good ten seconds you
know like when when somebody gets
knocked out or knocked down when they're
boxing
and they kind of sit back up at four
seconds but they wait till the nine and
a half second
mark to [ __ ] stand back up that's
what i did
and liab was going like dude you all
right you're all right i kept saying
yeah and i wasn't
and uh so i start walking down the hill
and um i'm kind of laughing because i
feel like a [ __ ] idiot but laughing
at this point hurts
because i guess you use those muscles in
your back
and uh i don't know about 30 seconds
later
lawhead's going yeah dude i can see
blood coming through
through your [ __ ] t-shirt
and uh yeah it was gross by the time i
got down to the bottom like my [ __ ]
t-shirt was like stuck to my back
and uh
you know but it wasn't bleeding perfect
it was more like the cut was more like a
scrape
because after i landed on the rock i
then slid down it
[Laughter]
so i lifted up my shirt and i go how bad
is it and i knew it was gonna be bad
because i knew what i did and not to
mention i'm a pasty [ __ ] redhead and
we don't bruise we look like you know
where somebody with pigment would look
like they had a bad bruise we look like
we got bitten by like a [ __ ] mako
shark that's basically what i look like
um
and uh you know i shook it off
went to the pharmacy got some neosporin
slapped it on my elbow left it off the
back figured the back was fine
and then i went and i got a salad
and that was my [ __ ] denver story how
was that
so uh my back has been killing me the
last couple of days and uh it's weird
when i
the only time it hurts is when i go to
stand up i gotta make a noise i'll make
the noise for you here let me see if i
can get it if it hurts
oh of course now it doesn't hurt
i think i did it i freed it up
all right that was a big that was like
geraldo looking into that safe sorry
about that um anyways let's get to some
[ __ ] advertising for this week
everyone i know this is kind of a
disjointed podcast this week uh
because i got up early where the [ __ ] is
it oh for christ's sake bill come on
come on can we do this all right
dollar shave club everybody you know
there are so many things in the world
that irritate me
uh you know slipping falling on a rock
inconsiderate [ __ ] uh the fact that i
have a motorcycle license but i'm too
scared to get one and drive one down the
street
well actually no you know what
considering what just happened to me
from a standing position i can't imagine
going 40 miles an hour and falling on
the tar
um that bugs me not being able to gash
your own people
you know what's the world coming to
uh when so many things can irritate you
why add razors to the list
it's time to stop milking your razor
blade i know with brand name razors
you're used to paying outrageous prices
and ex so then you then exhaust those
razors until they start to look like a
rusty soda can it's time to move on
everybody dollar shave club delivers
amazing quality blades to your door for
just a few bucks a month never think
about it again they send a pack every
month so you can change your blades
every week
uh i love these guys and your face is
going to love them too they've always
got a
[ __ ] come on bill they always got a
new product
oh they also got a new product called
one wipe charlie's
it's a butt wipe for men and it's classy
as opposed to those unclassy butt wipes
you know the ones i'm talking about
check out the video for that and sign up
for your razors today
go to dollarshaveclub.com forward slash
burr that's
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash burr
or go to billboard.com and click the
dollar shave club banner
and uh what's next hulu plus everyone
i'm sure you've tried hulu.com but i
want to tell you about hulu plus hulu
plus lets you watch thousands of hit
shows anytime anywhere streaming on your
tv or go with your smartphone or tablet
why stand in line or ride a train and
just stare at your feet you could be
watching your favorite shows on hulu
plus hulu plus is a great way to binge
watch your favorite shows too hulu plus
has tons of episodes from great comedies
like snl community modern family south
park family guy and thousands of other
shows plus it's only 7.99 a month that's
7.99 for all the shows and movies you
can watch catch up on current shows
binge on an old favorite or catch a
great movie you can do it all on hulu
plus right now you can try hulu plus for
a couple of weeks free on me when you go
to the podcast page at billboard.com and
click on the hulu plus banner or go to
huluplus.com bill please make sure you
use the huluplus.com banner i mean
huluplus.com
bill link so you can get an extended
free trial and so they know that we sent
you helps make us a little bit of money
right puts fruit loops on my table and
gives you a great deal one more time for
extended free trial huluplus.com bill
what else do we got here
um yeah that's it that's good for the
advertising for the moment
you know what i touched on there i
mentioned some of that serious stuff
about them uh
so theria are you syria
um
i mentioned that uh
you know
what's the deal there that they got a
little uh
they're getting some [ __ ] there for gas
and their own people i don't understand
that whole thing if you don't sign a
treaty saying that you're not going to
gas other people
i guess maybe they did i tried to figure
out whether they did or not and i got
onto this colored map of the world
where they had people who signed it
people who signed it and said to hell
with it and people who never signed it
and then people who sort of signed it
and there was all these colors and these
graphs i can't figure out if they signed
it or not but let's just say for the
sake of the argument that they went to
the geneva protocol in 1949 and they
decided that they were going to sign
that thing and they weren't going to gas
people
now as far as how it's written isn't it
written that basically you're not going
to get you don't gas our people and we
won't guess your people but there's is
there anything in there that says you
can't gas your own people
i'm not saying you could you should do
it
but those are your people right
like if i go out and buy myself a new
outfit
you know to show off my figure
there's nothing preventing me says i
can't go out and go jump in a mud puddle
right this is my [ __ ] clothes
now if i take those clothes off and then
throw them in some old lady's face now
now there's a problem
but if i just roll around in that mud
puddle i'm just doing damage to myself
aren't i
i don't [ __ ] know how dumb do i sound
right now well you know what you're dumb
too [ __ ] you it's a legitimate question
i don't understand why you can't gas
people you can't do that but you can
[ __ ] firebomb cities and you can
strafe people
you know you can do area bombing oops
did that land on a nursery with babies
why can you do that
you know what it is i think it's too
easy it i get it chemical weaponry
that's like the peds of of mass murder
all right
don't just send
that's what it is
being able to gas people that's like
everybody gets their own ribbon okay you
know what i worked it out you don't need
to write in but if you want to write in
i'd love to talk about it something
[ __ ] different
hey do you see that's that story espn
had that they ran with i guess very
little facts
at least according to the very pissed
off woman that i wrote i read her little
article about it they were trying to
claim that bobby riggs
threw that match against billie jean
king
i'm showing my age here i mean i don't
remember when this [ __ ] happened but
back in the 70s they had the battle of
the sexes
and bobby riggs a former champion 55
[ __ ] years old
plays billie jean king 29 the number one
seated woman's player
in the world at the time
and uh he played her and he lost and
evidently that was some sort of big
thing for women that a woman in her
prime
could beat an old man at tennyson
so now somebody was trying to claim that
was fixed it sounded like [ __ ] that
he threw the match because the saying
that i guess he played the number two
woman in the world and beat her handily
but there's a big difference between
number two and number one as you saw
yesterday
with uh serena
and uh
what's her face that she played they
[ __ ] battled for the first two sets
and then serena just took over was like
[ __ ] this you know what's so [ __ ]
hilarious about serena williams is when
she's playing tennis
i swear to god it's just
like she doesn't make too many noises
but she just looks like i would duck if
she hit the ball
you know
it's like a [ __ ] linebacker out there
right but then the second she wins the
match
she turns into a girl again like oh my
gosh she puts like her one hand up and
starts waving jumping up and down really
girly like but when she's playing the
game i swear to god
it's like you could she could [ __ ]
kill somebody so she's playing this
other lady
and i'm telling you they were playing
like dudes
there was some volleys a couple times
they went to the net but pretty much
they were just at the baseline
just power shots
[ __ ] home run hits i'll tell you i
was watching the packers
49ers and i started flipping over just
to see you know i mean how often do you
get to see a legend playing i mean she
went she just won her 18th major i think
so she's closing in on steffi graf and
then after steffi graf is at australian
broad i forget her name i know the guy
what is it not stan smith rod leyva he's
won the most of any guy
what the [ __ ] her name margaret or meg
she's got some one of those old people
[ __ ] m names
so she's closing in on her so i wanted
to watch a little bit of that it was a
[ __ ] great match
how the [ __ ] did i get onto this but
whatever that you know that that's
always bugged me
that bobby riggs thing when billie jean
beat bobby riggs like that proved
something see women in the prime of
their life are just as good as men whose
dicks don't really work anymore
and are in the early stages of prostate
cancer they can beat us at badminton
a faster game of badminton so i don't
know so some some woman wrote this
article you know
it doesn't matter whether it was fixed
or not it doesn't matter anymore like
the problem with women is they actually
give a [ __ ] what guys say
you gotta be like guys
if you really want to become free of men
this is what you have to do two things
you have to stop giving a [ __ ] what we
say
you have to talk down to us more
and then what you have to do is you have
to start your own [ __ ]
the problem with women
how many am i pissing off right now
is you keep trying to join our [ __ ]
you know we have a gym we have the water
buffalo's club and there's no women
allowed you should be like great
get the [ __ ] out of the house go down
there the same way we would do you think
we give a [ __ ] that you have a woman's
only gym
go down there
do a double session get the [ __ ] out of
it i don't care
especially now with all these great ways
of taping tv you can watch all these
[ __ ] games
by all means you know beat it beat it
right you know just get out of here you
guys you got to start having that
[ __ ] attitude
because
that's that's that's the genius of guys
is we act like we don't give a [ __ ]
about you but we do but we act like we
don't
and we act like what we're gonna go do
we're excited about it and you guys
drink that kool-aid and you actually
think what we're doing is exciting so
you want to become a part of it
you want to join our dumb gyms right you
want to join our [ __ ] golf clubs
because you think there's something
going on that you think you're actually
missing out on something you're not
it's a bunch of stupid guys walking
around scratching their dicks every
other [ __ ] sentence why would you
want to be around that
i don't want to be upon a bunch of women
like i don't even know what you guys
talk about to me it sounds like a bunch
of birds fighting over a french fry i
don't want to listen to that [ __ ]
all right
i love how like i'm berating you guys
out of [ __ ] nowhere i thought i
thought i was beyond this in my life
evidently i'm not
um
all right let's plow ahead here
everybody
you know what i did this this week i
really watched the offensive line of the
new england patriots that's what i did
and uh
i actually liked what i saw man i
thought they were protecting tom really
well and i think if you're a true if
you're a true football fan if you're a
true fan of your team you should know
your offensive line to the point where
you actually recognize them when they go
down the street
you know
if you actually know what who what ryan
wendell looks like
or dan conley
logan mankins nobody knows these [ __ ]
guys nate solder might i know they're
saying the [ __ ] names right because
you never hear them you know why because
they never get busted for holding
sebastian valmer
right
i actually paid attention to the
offensive line this week for the first
time in 30 years of watching football 35
[ __ ] years i actually noticed in the
huddle
how they're lined up how the offensive
line is lined up where they just turn
right around their right in position and
it's like of course they are bill you're
dumb [ __ ] the clock is ticking
what do you think they just all go into
the huddle all willy-nilly
is that because you never played
organized football i played for a few
weeks
i actually played for a few weeks this
is kind of a sad story and then daryl
stingley got paralyzed and my parents
got freaked out they uh
and actually i got to tell you uh you
know they had the foresight to see what
i was doing in my brain
playing football
and they also saw my athletic abilities
so it's just like you know they were
like he's already kind of dumb
and uh he's not uh the most athletic
person so why would we want him to sit
here smashing his head into another
third grader's head
let's have him play
take baseball
out to the ball game
hey how about those red sox huh god damn
it i wish i was watching baseball this
year you know how excited i would be i'm
not gonna lie to you i'm gonna jump on
the bandwagon come october i always
watch october baseball anyways i love it
like i don't know if they have extra
microphones or whatever but the just the
sounds of the ballpark is better but uh
you know taking three out of four from
the yankees that's pretty [ __ ]
impressive
and i and i really am kind of
amazed at the fact that that trade with
the dodgers worked out for both teams
that's so rare
in a blockbuster trade that it works for
both people that should have been like
great for one team and horrific for the
other or it should have just sucked for
both teams
like that's what usually happens in a
blockbuster trade
it either works for nobody bill you just
said it you don't need to repeat it but
very rare does it work out for both
teams
i don't know why those superstars
started playing for the dodgers but i'm
glad they did i've always liked the
dodgers
and uh i'm glad that we uh saved a bunch
of [ __ ] money and whoever the hell we
have on our team
is evidently playing [ __ ] great could
i say evidently one more [ __ ] time
with this podcast
um
evidently i can shoot another
um let's plow ahead here um
oh i was watching some great uh youtube
videos last night
um i've become obsessed
let me see i don't even know his [ __ ]
name it's great i've become obsessed
with him and i don't even know his
[ __ ] name
where the hell is it
ah for god's sakes
what the [ __ ] is this guy's name
you know what i i i just this is this is
why right here i at some point need to
bring somebody else into the [ __ ]
fold
so i can actually
where is it here we go put this on here
and then we hit mute so enough to pay
any money for the [ __ ] song
where the f god damn it
oh there it is
i've become obsessed with this drummer
uh james gadson
he basically a lot of people if you're a
bill withers fan
i highly recommend downloading uh still
still bill
uh it's incredible [ __ ] album bill
withers is one of the greatest singers
of all time and i also think
unbelievably underrated as a singer and
uh he's got this killer drummer james
gadson and just i don't know that guy
just doesn't get the attention he
deserves so long story short i started
you know youtubing him and watching him
playing there's not a lot of stuff on
him there's a lot of videos and [ __ ] of
interviews with him
and that led me to uh one of those great
youtube runs where you don't end up on a
slap fight you actually start to learn
stuff
and i came across
this other drummer
like fred
fred bellow i don't know how to say his
[ __ ] name which led me to this
concert film
and otis rush singing i can't quit you
baby
um
that led zeppelin did a remake of called
i can't quit you babe
as opposed to i can't quit you baby so
that's how they switched it up and then
that's why they never paid otis rush
until they settled out of court
i don't know if that's true if they had
to settle on a court with him i know
they had to do that a couple of times
but uh
otis rush
one of the greatest live singers i ever
heard
and he plays guitar left-handed and he
doesn't string it he plays a
right-handed guitar upside down and did
not string it the other way he just
plays it
upside down
strung right handed and the only other
guy i knew who did that was uh
was dick dale
i didn't know there was someone else who
did it but he's [ __ ] unbelievable i'm
gonna send you a link to this
concert film on the podcast this week
because you really should see it and
should know about this guy uh in case
you don't know about him and uh and also
i want to know
what concert this is if anybody has any
information on how somehow i can watch
the whole concert because
it's crazy it starts
with you know
this older black dude who's like playing
like boogie woogie piano and you see
he's part of that generation
and then it kind of leads into these
guys who are more r b guys and it's
right before uh
i don't know it seems it's like right
around that time right as james brown
was coming out or whatever but it's just
a great period where people can actually
play music and [ __ ] play instruments and
sing live it's [ __ ] awesome and then
they're playing performing of course to
this horrific white crowd that is just
sitting there
like their entire lives have been mapped
out in front of them and they made no
decisions and they have no passion in
life i don't know what it is it's
[ __ ] embarrassing but it's incredible
concert footage all right i'm done
running my [ __ ] mouth let's go to uh
let's go to some of your questions and
information this week uh i got a ton of
[ __ ] last week by saying a port
a pork shoulder was actually the ass of
the pig
i guess it actually is the shoulder i
guess a christmas ham is the ass
or you can eat it on thanksgiving just
say ham is the ass of the pig so this
guy says bill i love your podcast i'm a
former butcher and i wanted to correct
you on your smoke shoulder comment on
yesterday's podcast a pork shoulder is
the front shoulder on a pig the
confusing part is they are also called
pork butts it's not the butt the butt of
the pig is the ham hope this helps
um blah blah blah well you know what can
you write back why do they call it a
butt then
i have no idea why why do they call it
that all i know is it's [ __ ]
delicious as is the ass of the pig
i eat the whole [ __ ] pig wherever the
[ __ ] the bacon is
you know let me do they have classes
like that do they have a class that
teaches you how to butcher an animal
in case you know whenever the dollar
collapses and i'm out there i mean i
know how to shoot a bow and arrow now i
know how to [ __ ] gut a fish pretty
well
but i'd like to know how to [ __ ]
shoot a wild pig hey [ __ ] this i'm on
the billy red state tour people i'm
coming out to el paso i'm coming out to
san antonio if anybody out there goes
wild boar hunting i want to do that [ __ ]
i want to do it but i don't want to
[ __ ] kill one just for the sake of
killing it all right i want to [ __ ]
kill it clean it do the whole [ __ ]
thing you make me do all of this [ __ ]
uh i know animal lovers out there
probably don't like it i'm doing it not
to do it all the [ __ ] time i want to
have that skill
all right
i'm basically i'm slowly i want to
become macgyver
i want to know how to fire you know how
to shoot a fish with a bow and arrow
sort of
okay i know how to load a gun and shoot
it sort of
i got some vegetables growing around my
house kinda
so if i know how to take down a [ __ ]
pig
and got that [ __ ] thing it's got to
translate to a goddamn
deer right sort of the same [ __ ] i would
think
and then all i need to do is get a
helicopter license and i'm good to go i
know how to ride a motorcycle now you
see what i'm saying
so you got [ __ ] if you have a
helicopter
that like what i love about the
helicopter is you just go right up you
can escape so easily
it's almost like you literally know how
to fly
we're like you know with an airplane you
need that run and start
you know i don't [ __ ] know but
anyways if somebody wants to take me
wild boar hunting i would [ __ ] do
that in a second
i go down to l.l bean and show up with
my brand new i'm going hunting [ __ ]
looking like [ __ ]
you know like those old vietnam movies
when you first get there and you you
buckle your chin strap to your helmet
and then all the grizzled vet veterans
tell you not to do it because the
concussive force of the shells is going
to blow your [ __ ] head off
that type of stuff bill what are you
talking about i don't know i want to
shoot a pig
you know how [ __ ] great that would be
take that [ __ ] down
all right take that [ __ ] down
clean it
bring the [ __ ] meat home and then
smoke it on my [ __ ] grill
how much of a man i would feel like how
much cowardice
i could [ __ ] push down that i have
the [ __ ] part of me would really be
shut down and i wouldn't have to listen
to those voices in my head and for a few
minutes i could actually act like i was
actually a stud
hey [ __ ] you i have my dreams
you know
all right whatever 40 minutes in here we
go it's time to read some some of your
letters
uh seriously [ __ ] your american sports
another positive email here hi bill big
fan got tickets to see you in london in
december i i got to take a time out here
um the response to uh some of my shows
pretty much all of them over there has
been unbelievable in europe and i can't
thank you guys enough
uh we added a show in london added a
show in helsinki
how crazy is that and some promoter in
estonia just asked me to add i'm not
going to be able to do it this time but
i'm doing it next time
and uh
it's been unbelievable so uh
i'm really really
excited to go over there
i'm gonna in this time rather than just
going there and landing
and uh
you know being a zombie during the day
i'm coming over like three three four
days early
to uh
get acclimated i'm gonna actually go to
italy i haven't decided where yet
but uh i'm just gonna go there and eat
and uh i'm gonna try and see an opera
when i'm there in some old opera house
i don't have too much time to go there
i don't think i want to go to rome
and go to the see the roman coliseum i
feel like that's going to times square
that's what i've learned in my travel
you like you go to new orleans i guess
you have to see bourbon street but you
really don't want to be down there
that's just a bunch of drunk tourists
which you want to go down is i you know
you know what i'm not going to tell you
the cool places to go you got to go
there and talk to the locals because i
don't want to [ __ ] up the locals good
places to go
it's kind of like
you know
i stayed at one of the greatest [ __ ]
hotels i've ever stayed at when i was in
colorado
and uh
i'm not going to tell you guys where it
is
because i don't want to ruin it
if you just by dumb luck discover it
it's [ __ ] amazing
we stayed at this place
and for dinner
we had lamb and elk
and uh
it was this quiet town off the beaten
path and they had this little [ __ ]
bar that we went to
where like the bartender wasn't even
behind the bar she was over in the
middle of shooting pool one of those
kinds of things and for the first time
in my life like country music made sense
i finally realized i knew willie nelson
was good i didn't know he was that good
all right and i went up to the [ __ ]
jukebox and i just started every [ __ ]
legendary
country guy that i knew
you know i threw in a couple of [ __ ]
rock songs or whatever but
you know merle haggard all these guys
and i and i wouldn't pick they'd have
their greatest hits i wouldn't go off
that i go off i'd pick a different album
then pick like the third track
rather than the first track because they
usually lead with the radio hit i wanted
to hear something different dude and i
[ __ ] loved it
so uh but that was weird i got to la and
i tried to download some willie nelson
and didn't feel the same way
you know so i'm gonna download some
[ __ ] some of that [ __ ] for my drive
from el paso to san antonio this week
uh playing el paso on thursday and then
san antonio on friday uh there's still
some tickets left in el paso i mean they
picked a really big place because
uh it was either play a little place or
there was they didn't have the middle
ground one so
we just picked a big place i don't know
if they're gonna close out the balcony
or whatever but there's definitely
tickets left
but then after that i drive down to san
antonio listen to this [ __ ] amazing
week
and then saturday i'm hanging around
and i'm going me and verzi are going on
a couple other buddies we're going to go
to the
texas a m alabama game
gonna go see johnny football go up
against
one of the great [ __ ]
college football teams i mean the run
that alabama's on is [ __ ] insane
being an lsu fan and [ __ ] annoys the
[ __ ] out of me
but uh
you can't not appreciate it so we're
gonna go to that game and that's gonna
be our week
so uh
anyways
so i'm trying to do more of that type of
stuff when i do the road and as a comic
it's great because you get excited to go
on the road when you plan [ __ ] like that
and it if you're excited you don't dry
up you just don't start hating your act
and you don't end up like just saying
[ __ ] it yet hosting a game show
not to say there's anything wrong with
that and not to say that i would never
host a game show that might become a
point in my [ __ ] career where i just
can't do it anymore
and i'll go on and i'll [ __ ] host
card sharks the new card sharks with
bill burr all of it higher you're gonna
risk all of it here we go i mean that
could be fun
you know what's great about being a game
show host you know you got a [ __ ]
fat ass [ __ ] house with an in-ground
pool and at that point who gives a [ __ ]
right
and every [ __ ] woman who comes on the
show
they [ __ ] they they i don't know they
make you feel special oh my god i watch
a show every day
[ __ ] kiss you on the cheek or you can
be a pervert like richard dawson and
kiss him on the mouth remember him
uh
who knows i might do that
when i get a little older but i still
got some fight me all right
this business hasn't dragged me in the
boat yet i'm on the hook without a doubt
they're reeling me in but i'm not on the
boat yet they haven't they haven't
[ __ ] clubbed me yet
so um
yeah so that's my thing i'm gonna go to
[ __ ] italy and i'm gonna go see an
opera
bring a little [ __ ]
handkerchief there and hope i actually
it moves me
rather than sitting there going like
dude i don't get what they're talking
about why is he so fat dude that skinny
chick would never hook up with that fat
guy i don't want to be that dude so
anyways let's get to the question here
i'm in the uk i listen to your podcast
and i hear the names of these little
teams
and games that you have uh
that you have there so last night i'm
going to bad
and i'm i've been slowly growing this
tiny amount of gambling money just small
change just so just for fun and i
thought i'd drop it on a
i drop it on a banker
that was played while i slept and i have
a little bit of interest in the morning
okay this guy's i like this guy he's
he's doing his little train spotting
slang here and i'm trying to figure it
out
drop it on a banker means you want to
put money on the game
so you're putting up money on a game
overseas and while you're sleeping
you're going to wake up and see if you
made any money or not
wow dude you just took gambling to a
whole lot you're a [ __ ] international
gambler
dude do you have like a [ __ ] white
tuxedo that you get up and put on like
roger moore
that's kind of [ __ ] fun
that's actually you know for people have
a serious gambling problem they probably
didn't need to know that because the
only time a serious gambler's not
gambling is probably when he's going to
sleep this [ __ ] is in so goddamn
deep he figured out a way to do it
i commend you and i also feel bad for
you sir
that's [ __ ] amazing so anyways he
goes i went to my bookmakers the
bookmaker's site and saw the yankees
beating the red sox eight to three
they were giving
odds on the red sox nine to one
in a horse race and a one to one hundred
on the yankees so i put the equivalent
of thirty dollars on the yankees and
thought ah [ __ ] it's an extra thirty
cents i'll have in the morning so wait a
minute you can bet on a game that's
already going
so it's eight to three
dude why wouldn't you have taken the
[ __ ] oh you did take the yankees
right
wait the yankees were beating the red
sox eight to three
i gotta i'm dumb people i gotta work
this out they were giving odds on the
red sox nine to one okay so you gotta
put up 900 bucks to make 100 at that
point or nine dollars to make one bill
they took out the zeros they tried to
make it easy for you
and then the yankees you throw down a
dollar you can make a hundred
so you said [ __ ] it
there's no way the yankees are going to
lose
and let's see you could have made 30
cents you put down what 300 bucks
is that how it works
where did you put down three three bucks
you put down three bucks you cheap [ __ ]
you bitching about three bucks
ah [ __ ] i don't know what's going on in
this so anyways he said what what the
[ __ ] sort of mickey mouse [ __ ] team
are the yankees to [ __ ] that up so bad
it's brutal losing 30 oh 30 bucks losing
30 bucks trying to win 30 cents
dude the math doesn't
oh yeah that's right that's right okay
mate 30 cents imagine i could be
fighting in a war alongside you guys
with a bag of live hand grenades on my
back
yeah dude i don't know how you made the
lep from the leap from [ __ ] uh
that game
to fighting in a war
i don't know what kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] goes to sleep trying to make 30
cents serves your right you cheap [ __ ]
you should have bet the underdog wait
you did no you didn't you bet the
favorite
well you know what your deal is you guys
overseas all you know is the yankees the
same way over here all we know is uh
what the [ __ ] are they uh uh man united
that's the only team we know i mean i
know some of the arsenal or arsenal i
don't know is liverpool but i don't know
what they're called
i just know man united
manchester united that's all i [ __ ]
know and you know what i don't like them
because their shit's over here and
they're like the [ __ ]
i i don't know i don't i don't like the
team that everybody likes you know [ __ ]
them so i'm sorry sir i'm sorry you lost
30 dollars trying to make 30 cents would
that even buy you half a [ __ ]
cup of tea or whatever the [ __ ] you
gonna do over there buy you one chip for
your fish and chip [ __ ] breakfast
um anyways but either way dude thanks
for uh buying tickets to the uh the
london show uh
like i said it really is humbling to
have that if i can use that [ __ ]
phrase without getting trash it really
is that people over there give a [ __ ]
want to come out so i hope i'm funny
um all right ken burns
dear billy boy
i heard you talking about the ken burns
documentary recently and wanted to turn
on turn you on to one of his
documentaries that i have yet to see but
i hear is great um and for those who
haven't been listening the past few
weeks i've been slowly when i have the
time getting through uh ken burns the
war it's all about world war ii i think
i'm through five episodes
it's a seven part series and
it is
absolutely [ __ ] incredible the
footage
i think a lot of the footage like they
wouldn't show
for the longest time like that he really
shows
the uh
it's it's not a propaganda film put it
that way it's it's an absolutely
astounding thing to watch
it's so amazing it's actually caused me
to i'm starting to read not only read
but read about the war and
for a dummy like me to actually want to
go out and start reading books
um although i had to take a break
because it was so [ __ ] heavy some of
the [ __ ] uh that right now i'm reading
uh
that guy from ministry i'm reading his
autobiography and if uh
you want to feel better about some of
the choices you've made in life like
maybe you think i'm a piece of [ __ ] i
did this i did that i partied too much
you got to read this guy's book you're
going to feel like you don't have any
sort of substance abuse problem i'm not
[ __ ] on the guy the guy's [ __ ]
genius
and i'm totally late to the party when
it comes to great music from the 80s i
listened to so much [ __ ] music
in the 80s and i completely missed out
on all this amazing stuff
that was going on ministry being one of
them and what's funny is the song that i
like the best
he hates
and says he hates it because
the people who like it are like people
who are into metal
uh it's stigmata i [ __ ] love it and i
like it because it sounds like a metal
song with all this in
industrial [ __ ] going i don't even know
anything about it he would cringe if he
heard any of this but i actually had to
put the book down and started laughing
because he totally
called me out as i'm reading the book
uh he was saying that it was just a
throwaway song but anyways it's on this
album called uh the land of rape and
honey which is
i guess is a [ __ ] classic and i never
heard anything about it because i was
listening to motley crue theater of pain
when that came out
um
so anyways
so he says it let me get back to this so
he says ken burns has another great
documentary by the way i'm watching all
i'm watching all of ken burns
documentaries
uh on netflix uh i've i'm doing civil
war next but this guy's actually
suggesting uh he's uh there's a new one
called uh prohibition
he goes i haven't seen it yet because
i'm in the middle of a book about
prohibition but i find the whole subject
fascinating not only because it talks
about how the majority of the working
class were drunks but it gets all into
the politics and cultural issues
associated with drinking back in the day
and how the breweries changed america
also america also there are many
similarities to the whole weed movement
we see nowadays
did you ever find yourself in a dry
county or a state where you can't find
uh beer in the grocery store well some
of our alcohol related laws can be
traced back to prohibition and the crazy
[ __ ] that caused it our drunken
forefathers
uh you know what's funny dude you're
just like me you spent you spelled
forefathers f-o-u-r
as in one two three four isn't it
f-o-r-e
i don't [ __ ] know uh our drunken
forefathers would get out of their
industrial jobs at the end of the day
look to decompress a bit and stay in
pubs all night soon enough these guys
started bringing home stds to their
wives and banging all the [ __ ] that
also stayed in the pubs all night their
wives started getting upset and fast
forward a bit and then you have
prohibition some guys just ruin it for
everyone
really well i knew it kind of came out
of the church
i didn't know that i just heard somebody
say that and i took it as law
thanks for the heads up
and thanks everybody seriously when you
guys write in you actually i know we
[ __ ] around a lot of this thing but when
you have something that will actually
make you
a more informed person or actually
it's a great piece of entertainment
please send it my way because i would
like to do
rather than just give out bad advice to
you guys i would like to actually try to
make your lives a little bit better on
some
on some level
and you know what here's a great way to
make your lives better people legal zoom
oh what a segway
snuck that one in on any snuck that one
in on you didn't i can you tell i've
been up since five in the morning i
can't even talk uh a lot of prizes legal
zoom everybody a lot of pride comes
along with starting your own dream
business absolutely i couldn't agree
more legal zoom but think about the
stress you feel if you don't take the
right steps to legally protect your
business and personal assets from the
beginning that's why i william burr
recommend legalzoom.com
during the past 12 years over a million
businesses business owners have trusted
legalzoom to help start their business
legalzoom will save you a lot of time
and money
not only money a pile of money on
startup costs plus they'll provide
solutions to help you run a successful
business legalzoom can provide self-help
services at your specific at your
specific direction or connect you with
an attorney but they are not a law firm
just to let you know just go to
legalzoom.com today to see what uh to
see what's right for you form an llc get
a dba incorporate or form a non-profit
all starting at just 99 bucks plus
you'll save even more when you enter bur
burr in the fir in the referral box at
checkout that's legalzoom.com promo code
burr one more time legalzoom.com promo
code burr
is that it
oh no i missed one here
evoice everyone if you're an
entrepreneur if you're an entrepreneur
and a customer calls do you want to seem
like you're in a high-rise window view
let's start this one again shall we
let's give e-voice the read they deserve
e-voice everybody
if you're an entrepreneur and a customer
calls do you want to seem like you're in
a high-rise window view fancy pants
office or do you want them to know
you're sitting in your underwear i think
that's an easy one right with your
e-voice
you can create the appearance of an
entire building sales customer support
tech support you name it it's going to
seem like you have it give your
customers the royal treatment with
e-voice e-voice will forward business
calls to your home mobile or any number
you choose wherever you are e-voice will
find you don't have time to take a call
no problem it's routed to your voicemail
and you can read it at your convenience
as an email if you like e-voice not only
gives you an edge over your competitors
it takes away the edge the big companies
have over you right now and now you can
try evoice for free for 30 days
one whole month unless it's a month of
31 days but they make it up in february
go to evoice.com and use promo code bill
bill that's evoice.com promo code bill
or just go to the podcast page at
billboard.com and click on the e-voice
banner and there you go those are the
ads for this week all right let's get
back to some of your questions here or
your information
um hairy situation
is what this one is called all right
what are you guys thinking harry's
situation
he either did something he shouldn't
have done and he's waiting for the other
shoe to drop
or uh he hooked up with a beautiful girl
who's going oh
natural oh
all right
hey bill funny show
great
that's what he just started with no
punctuation whatsoever whatsoever hey
bill funny show great
all right maybe this guy's from overseas
or maybe he's down south and you can
make it there by land
who knows he goes i have a question for
your mm podcast my girlfriend who i have
lived with for the last seven years is
starting to constantly ask me to shave
my chest oh i went the other way oh you
went the other way
um i'm pretty hairy
but not [ __ ] chewbacca hairy just
mainly my chest
this is not a problem but sometimes she
won't have sex with me until i do
whoa
all right that's that's uh okay that's
red flag number one for me
unless you're
you're not perceptive as to uh how hairy
your chest is
uh it can take over an hour to properly
to do properly and sometimes i can't be
[ __ ] after a hard day's work
so i just rub one out i know times
change because in the 70s harry was sexy
but now every pop star is starting to
look more like a woman i swear justin
bieber is prettier than half the women
i've banged what do you think
um
yeah that whole manscape looked i guess
is is supposed to be in i have no idea
but um
i find it odd
i don't find it odd that your your
girlfriend is asking you to uh you know
maybe trim down your chest a little bit
but the fact that she won't even have
sex with
you um
i don't know what happened
did some pervert with the [ __ ]
full full chest of hair [ __ ] lay down
on top of her and do something to her
like that's kind of weird to me
like how do you think she would feel if
you were like hey can you uh i don't
know trim up here or there or i
literally can't have sex with you that's
kind of [ __ ] up
she's really making you
jump through some hoops there um so
you're either way hairier than you're
letting on
i i get women being grossed out by back
hair
you know especially those guys who have
it like up on their shoulders and then
they just have like the two patches just
above the kidney and just below the
shoulder blade there's those two like
they got
i don't know
like they got hugged by someone who
jerked off too much
[Laughter]
um i would sit down with her and just be
like listen i'm not going to say i'm not
going to [ __ ] shave my chest but it's
kind of
weird to me that if i don't
you don't even find me sexually
attractive i mean what are you having
sex with my chest are you into me i mean
i could see if this is a one-night stand
you're like listen i'm into this i'm not
into that
do this do this and for the love of god
shut the [ __ ] up all right you have your
little grocery list on how you need what
you need me to do to get you there i get
that but if i'm in a [ __ ]
relationship with you
you know that's that's kind of a
but you know you didn't really even ask
that i don't know what the [ __ ] you
asked me
um
it takes you an hour to do it don't they
have like those [ __ ] things you can
just kind of
i don't know that's weird
that's [ __ ] weird to me
i would i would that would be my biggest
concern i would be asking you know like
what you can't even have sex with me
i you know what i understand on your
face because some women have sensitive
skin you know
and you know
if you're on top of her missionary style
you know pumping away if you're out of
shape you laying your head right down
next to her
[Laughter]
they can get a little razor burn on the
side of their face i understand that if
you have like
you have like a beard
well if you have whiskers i i [ __ ]
get that [ __ ]
can i just do that again well i'm not
gonna do it because some people that
might hurt your [ __ ] ears um
i understand that but chest hair
why don't you why don't you come up with
like a a compromise be like all right
how about
if my chest is too hairy we still bang i
just do a doggy style
i promise after i get to where i need to
go i won't collapse down on top of you
making you feel like you know burt
reynolds just got out of the pool and is
using you to towel off i won't do that
okay maybe he could do that
or just sit down with her and just be
like listen i'm not trying to be a dick
here what is your issue with harry chess
and uh
because it's you know you know what's
funny i'm getting more weirded out by it
by
than you are i'm probably putting bad
ideas in your head so i'm just going to
shut the [ __ ] up
um all right military history
oh this is a great one hey grateful red
ah i love it
just when you think they've run out of
creative ways
ah that's a good one
uh the past couple of shows you
mentioned you enjoy reading about world
war ii just wanted to give you a couple
of recommendations first i'd like to
mention uh oh before he gets going i i
read that book uh fly boys
which i swear to god is not about boy
bands it was by i forget who wrote it ah
jesus christ i'm the worst the same guy
who did flags of our fathers um wrote
the same thing anyways the past couple
of shows you mentioned blah blah blah
books on world war ii going to give you
a couple recommendations first i'd like
to mention
dan carlin's part podcast
hardcore history i'm telling you it's
right up your alley dude good call i'm
listening to that
he's covered many aspects of history
from the bronze age to the relatively
modern age
if he can make the bronze age which i
don't even know what that is
like uh i can't deal with
you know the only people i can really
read about
from
way back in the day
which is basically anything before
cowboys and indians
is you have to be a mass murdering
psychopath like i can read about the the
inquisitions
uh or the inquisition i don't [ __ ]
know if it's plural or not i agreed
about that genghis khan or i can read
about
um attila the hun
you know basically the original
scarfaces i can read about those guys
and uh but other [ __ ] you know ancient
medieval history and the [ __ ]
lilliputians were going up against the
[ __ ] uh persian
empire i don't [ __ ] i i don't know i
can't deal with that [ __ ]
um so if he can make that ex interesting
i
i don't know maybe i could listen to
enough of it and actually sound
intelligent who knows
so anyways he says uh
but i suggest his series ghost
ghost of the the
what is that ost front
it's the mind-blowing but little talked
about conflict between the russians and
the germans yeah they really do skip
over that um in fact a lot of
you people don't live in this country a
lot of what they talk about in world war
two they do talk about pearl harbor
which set the whole thing off but
there's very they don't talk even about
the japanese that much the kind of pearl
harbor
uh they were winning at first battle of
midway and then we're dropping the two
[ __ ] bombs and that's it and then you
watch jaws and you hear about the
indianapolis right
600 men go in the water
that's all you learn right but they
mainly talk about
fighting the germans
and mainly d-day
basically from france going right into
german concentration camp
schindler's list all right hitler kills
himself in the bunker game set match
wipe your hands of it
all right then we're immediately into
the cold war but they also ignore
you know fighting the germans in africa
uh fighting the italians in italy there
and how we went about it and all the
stuff that happened and uh
and then they certainly don't talk about
all we hear about the the russians is
basically
they just retreated
and they drew them in and then when the
winner came they just mercifully hacked
them to death all the way back to
[ __ ] berlin that's all we hear i
didn't know that they were just
first of all as they were retreating
they were blowing up their own bridges
and dams and just
scorched the scorched earth thing that
they did literally destroyed their own
[ __ ] country so there was nothing
there for the germans it was [ __ ]
brilliant
and absolutely [ __ ] ruthless i would
love
you know what
that's something i'm gonna do on the
road thank you very much what a
wonderful suggestion i got two there
do you know what's great about those
both of those will make me more informed
and hopefully a better person look at
you guys paying it forward
maybe i can uh give somebody some good
advice here well let me just continue
here says incidentally i discovered your
podcast because of him he was a guest on
the joe rogan experience and i started
listening to joe rogan regularly which
led me to your glorious show oh wasn't
that great yeah rogan's done a lot for
me he really has when he hyped that um
[Music]
that yoko owner thing i did that thing
was like a year old
and then he talked about it and then
that was it there was like a zillion
people he's like if he has like oprah
winfrey level power like remember when
oprah winfrey said hey man i don't think
he should be eating red meat anymore and
all of texas declared war on her because
she had that level of power that's what
rogan is
in like the podcast world if that
[ __ ] guy says hey check out this
thing all of a sudden like it gets a
million hits
so uh
i got to do something for him
what what what what do you get
what do you get for joe rogan i should
buy him a new pair of mitts
you know buy him his [ __ ] vitamins
for the week some sort of workout [ __ ]
nah nah nah he has all of that stuff
i got to go against the grain with joe
rogan
what should i you know i'd buy him a
nice sun hat
you know
really thoughtful gift like joe i know
you have every everything that involves
choking somebody out or ending their
life if they [ __ ] with you on any level
you know i want a nice sun hat
has anybody done anything to help keep
the sun out of that wonderful man's eyes
i don't think they have
i think he's comfortable enough with
himself that he could accept the
unbelievably awkward intimate moment of
me handing him that hat you know what
next time i do his [ __ ] podcast i'm
bringing him a nice sun hat
you know i don't know you might have a
convertible who knows
is there such a thing as a sun hat
there's a sun dress
did i just invent a new [ __ ] hat
there you go people right there look at
me creating a whole new business
creating jobs here at the monday morning
podcast either way listen to the joe
rogan experience and when you're done
doing that by the way
uh me and al madrigal and some other uh
wonderful people have started the all
things comedy network if you like this
podcast if you'd like to have a nice
incredible wide variety of podcasts to
listen to i suggest you go to the all
things comedy podcast network and uh
have a listen harlan williams tom papa
uh
baron vaughn
tom seguro uh with the the [ __ ] uh
we got all kinds of people
your mom's house podcast every you would
think i have them in front of me
mini van men there's all kinds of great
ones harlan's highway
all right here we go from a lady hiya
bill
hi you kid uh lady listener here i have
two questions in one email i hope that's
all right with you well absolutely
i'm just psyched that a woman actually
is listening to this podcast and wants
to contribute i've been asking you guys
borderline begging you
you know
to get out of the kitchen
figure out how a computer works and send
me an email but you just you know you're
too busy making a sandwich for the man
in your life which is what you're
supposed to do
you know but you know every once in a
while don't be afraid of the computer
ladies
um
all right lady listen okay the two
questions the first one is about
marriage
i'm just wondering how how do you feel
about it i'm only 18 and seeing what it
is doing to my parents recently is
making me not open to the idea in the
future
um all right well this is the thing just
because your parents don't seem to have
a happy marriage doesn't mean that you
can't
all right
i think uh if you're going to to being
married married for the right reasons
and if you're uh
you're mature enough which i've never
have been
and i've been a [ __ ] complete piece
of [ __ ] with women and all that type of
stuff and i've been
as your 20s are coming up
um
you know
as your 20s are coming up you know
you're going to meet some people that
you're going to look at
and you're going to feel like you have a
heart attack and
don't [ __ ] walk away from go up to
that person
just because your parents maybe haven't
found true love doesn't mean
you can't
and you know you can find true love and
then if you work at it
and you do the things you're supposed to
do what you'll learn naturally as you
get older you can have a great time
you know is there anything better than
seeing like two old people
sitting together and you can see they
still have that connection and they got
to they literally enjoyed life together
well i wish i knew when i was younger
how important that was
you know i'm finally starting to see it
through all of my [ __ ] horrific
mistakes that i've made in that category
but like uh
um
i think you should be open to it you
should be open to
you're 18 you should be open to things
i'm not saying drug use and being
promiscuous and that type of thing smart
[ __ ] i mean
uh finding love you should definitely be
open to
not happy particularly your parents and
you're like this just seems like a lot
of work
to just be miserable
um
that doesn't mean you have to be
miserable all right
there you go so that's your first one
all right my second question she says is
about how and when one should introduce
a significant other to parents
um
just to give you more information my
boyfriend's 21 and in the last year of
college we've been together for about a
year and five months
all right that's some scary math there
depending on what state you're in
uh
every time i'm going to hang out with
him or have a sleepover at his house
i've been making up an excuse
like i'm going
to a concert that ends really late gonna
stay with a friend i can't seem to work
up the nerve to tell either my mom or
dad
i'm more worried about my dad because
he's a [ __ ] big mouth the whole
family would know by the end of the
night when he's drinking on weekends he
likes to bring up conversations just to
work on people's nerves in the house i
don't want my boyfriend to be the topic
in the house for my dad to get on my
nerves with so do i just go with the
if it ain't broke don't fix it root and
keep making shitty excuses until they
either find out on their own or i move
out of the house or do i just work up
some balls here and tell them that i
have a boyfriend
well
they're going to find out eventually
and when they find out you're not going
to have control over the situation
so
um
i kind of got lost there were you
you make up excuses to your parents or
to your boyfriend
let me go back here my second question
is how about
how do i introduce my boyfriend to my
parents okay
every time i'm gonna hang out with him
or sleep over his house i've been making
up excuse oh okay okay okay okay
uh this is what i would do they are
probably the more you say i'm going to
another concert that's going to end late
they're going to figure it out how do
you introduce
your parents uh
to your boyfriend i would just i would
do this
i wouldn't say [ __ ] to your parents
other than i have a boyfriend now and i
want to introduce them to you guys
and i would leave it at that
because your parents are your parents
and they're going to behave how they
behave and then what i would do is i
would give a pregame speech to uh to
your boyfriend
and be like look
i love my parents they're a little bit
nuts
and this is the thing too you're
probably going to overreact
you know you'd like the fear you have of
what they're going to do is going to be
so much bigger probably than what
they're actually going to do it's
because they're your parents you want
their approval and you [ __ ] hate them
all at this
and it's gonna be like uh just walking
into a store like hello sir can i help
you yes i'd like that shirt there you go
that'll be 9.95 thank you goodbye it's
going to be at that level a little bit
more
um it's just gonna be nice they're just
gonna be exchanging niceties okay that's
what i'm predicting is gonna happen and
then what's gonna happen is when he when
your boyfriend leaves he's gonna tell
you how nice your parents are
because why wouldn't you and then that's
probably going to annoy you on some
level because you're going to be like no
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] you haven't had
to live with them so don't do that to
him either
um i would take control of the situation
and just introduce him
um
and if they ask how long you've been
seeing them
you know when you first say i want you
to introduce i want to introduce my
boyfriend to you and if they ask how
long you've been seeing them
i don't know your dad drinks and he says
[ __ ] you might want to lie about that i
don't know i'll [ __ ] him if he does
don't lie to him
say about a year and five months
and if they say well why haven't you
brought him around just be like well dad
because you have a tendency to get drunk
and talk about everybody's business and
it was really
uh made me nervous that's why i didn't
you can't [ __ ] with the truth
what's he gonna say to that
i don't get drunk and say all that type
of [ __ ]
i guess he could be in denial
i don't know at some point you know what
you have to do you gotta like
you you gotta man up or one man up and
you just have to live your [ __ ] life
and you just have to understand that
your parents are your parents they're
[ __ ] awesome but they're just people
and you just really have to uh
in a healthy way not give a [ __ ] what
they think anymore
in a healthy way okay i don't mean like
like i said go out and start doing drugs
and being a [ __ ] idiot um
you should always care about
not bringing shame
to your family name but like as far as
that other stuff like i wanted you to be
a doctor but you're gonna [ __ ] i
don't know
open your own bakery
i'm so disappointed well be disappointed
okay because i don't want to [ __ ] sit
there vacuuming out somebody's ass
or looking at somebody's toes or working
on a brain whatever the [ __ ] doctor
does
i want to make pop tarts all right
that's going to make me happy if you
can't accept that then i don't tell you
all right people that is the podcast for
this week i hope you enjoyed it um
here's the big old wrap up here now that
the show is over
don't forget to sign up for your uh well
before i do the wrap-up let me uh
let me type some of my gigs like i said
i'm gonna be at uh
i'm gonna be in el paso
this thursday night san antonio friday
night the following weekend
i'm going to be in west virginia
pittsburgh at the heinz theater and then
i'm going to be up in toronto ontario
at the just for last festival
and uh the week after that i'm going to
be doing uh
two shows at the prestigious chicago
theater
and where else chicago illinois
that's what i got coming up all right
then i know i got a san jose
seattle arizona run
in the beginning of october
that's it all right okay there you go
that's the podcast
for this week if you like my comedy
please download my special off my
podcast of my i'm sorry if my website
and if you'd like a hard copy version
you can also get that
makes a wonderful gift especially for
someone that you don't really give a
[ __ ] about but you have to get him a
gift give him a [ __ ] dvd all right
here's the wrap up everybody now that
the show's over don't forget to sign up
for your free trial of hulu plus hulu
plus lets you binge on thousands of hit
shows anytime anywhere on your tv pc
smartphone or tablet support this
podcast once again and get an extended
free trial of hulu plus when you go to
the podcast page at billboard.com and
click on the hulu plus banner or go to
billboard oh sorry or go to huluplus.com
bill once again that's huluplus.com bill
thank you for listening that's the
podcast for this week go [ __ ] yourselves
and
i'll talk to you next week